it's a very interesting weekend that's
Luke that's not me Serge what are you
doing oh it's just
I'm used to pushing that top corner so
we're in uh we're in a a mobile Studio
setup in Austin Texas because uh we're
here all week we got a bunch of amazing
guests and we're doing a live show this
Friday but let's talk about news that's
what you're here for it was a crazy
weekend Donald Trump tweeted just World
War III that's all he said and then he
gets a whole bunch of news written about
him and China says they're ready to
fight oh boy Pentagon leaked documents
suggests Russia is actually winning and
surprise surprise they're lying to US
unless those League documents are
actually just propaganda propaganda and
uh in and unto themselves but you know
what I wanted to leave with a story that
I think was kind of a white pill moment
that would be inspiring for all of you
and that's Anheuser-Busch has seen a
multi-billion dollar market cap drop off
since the start of this controversy when
they hired Dylan Mulvaney reportedly
sales are dropping rumors are
circulating that they're not selling
product videos are popping up below the
internet showing beer sections where the
Budweiser and the bush products are all
still there and other companies are all
sold out this could all be propaganda
too but you know what I want to at least
believe that we can win if we organize
and you know what is also true it's
entirely possible the naysayers who are
acting like this is not a big deal are
actually the propagandists trying to say
stop doing what you're doing when in
reality I look at the Hard numbers since
the start of this controversy their
stock is down I think around five
percent for a multi-billion dollar
market cap drop so uh we can organize we
can vote with our dollars and we can win
so we got a lot of stuff to talk about
but before we get into all that let me
try and slide forward in this awkward
situation and
everyone head over to timcast.com become
a member by clicking join us to join our
members we're having we're we're doing
we can here with this mobile studio so
thanks for hanging out but uh click join
us become a member support our work as a
member you'll get access to our members
only uncensored show we're gonna have
one of those up tonight at about 10 10
p.m eastern time and you can also join
our Discord server where you can chat
with a whole bunch of like-minded people
and after you've been a member for six
months you get access to the VIP chat
and voice chat voice chat where you can
submit questions actually call in and
ask us questions and you can jump the
line if you want by signing up for 25
bucks per month and then of course we
have the elite club which is more
community building and we got a bunch of
really cool programs every Friday we're
going to start shouting out members
projects companies or otherwise because
y'all are actually the people sponsoring
the show already so Friday will be your
day so smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share the show with your
friends joining us tonight to talk about
all of this and a whole lot more is
Peter bagosian hey thanks for having me
Doctor Peter no Peter Peter's fine but
you're a doctor right correct but
Peter's Peter Peter's fine so don't
listen to anybody because they're a
doctor in fact it probably means if they
got their degree recently it's probably
a bad thing it probably is an indication
that they're brainwashed but for people
who aren't familiar uh I mean aside from
a whole bunch of accolades I think a lot
of people might know you from what the
so-called squared hoax where you Helen
pluck Rose and James Lindsey created
these uh what would you what would you
call them woke fake papers woke papers
that we played on the moral prejudices
of journals and showed that the bodies
of literature were corrupt the bodies of
literature by the way that were forming
public policies upon so simply put
you uh in one instance took a chapter
from mineconf correct and changed it to
a feminist talking points like you
changed key pronouns to feminist pronoun
like feminist nouns and they accepted it
yeah we had two two papers one we just
changed Jews for white men and the other
one we we
thank you and and the other one we we
rewrote with that in mind so it's good
to be here with everybody yeah and uh I
think we have a lot to talk about
considering what's going on with the
anheuser-bush thing wokeness now there's
talk about the Mario movie making a
bunch of money and uh so we'll talk
about that stuff and then of course
Riley Gaines is a big story University
of San Francisco that's a big story in
my in my world I think it's massive she
got attacked she was chased by a a mob
yeah and then locked in a room for what
three hours so we'll get in all that
stuff we'll get into it and what's
really fascinating to me that's
interesting but the University's
response is what we should drill down on
right on absolutely and Luke
gradkowski's here well yeehaw welcome
back beautiful and amazing human beings
it's good to be back the dollar is
collapsing the Petro dollar is being
replaced the proxy war is expanding
everything we told you was going to
happen is happening but it's happening
on a bigger scale so things are going to
get a lot crazier it's good to be back
since we're in Texas I decided to wear
my ROM Paul if I told you so was a
person shirt which you could get on the
best politicalshirts.com good to see you
guys it's been a while the most Cowboy
you've ever been I know you love it you
got to fit in Yeehaw hey Peter what's
your doctorate in uh education nice well
hey I'm Ian Crossland let's get going
let's jump to this uh this this first
story right here yeah we got Serge he's
not on the my he's not on the camera so
yeah no camera distance all right let's
uh let's jump to this first story we got
this from The Daily Mail Bud Lights VP
says she wanted to update the fratty and
out of touch branding with inclusivity
days before Dylan Mulvaney's
controversial partnership with beer was
unveiled and uh I'm gonna humble brag
here I called this in my conversation
with Vivek ramaswamy when I said what's
likely happening is these Millennial
women are getting promoted in these
companies they hold these views then
they start adopting these things it is
not it is not like some 56 year old gen
xer or whatever running the company said
this is what we got to do it is a young
Millennial person taking these jobs but
of course what everyone really came here
for is this tweet from DC Drano he says
on March 31st Anheuser-Busch had a
132.38 billion dollar market cap as of
today it is now 100
128.4 billion you know what that means
the woke Bud Light campaign has already
shaved off nearly 4 billion in company
value don't let Democrats lie to you
conservative boycotts work so uh a white
pill moment I suppose boycotts do work
voting with your dollar does work and
this one is the easiest thing for people
to do because everyone's always like
what can I do I don't want to risk my
family I don't know how I can affect the
the electoral system who do I vote for I
can only vote every few years this one's
really easy don't buy Bush don't buy
Anheuser products don't buy Budweiser
don't buy Bud Light and if if this can
be kept up that's the that's the thing
right there right so it's only worked if
it can be kept up
so it's got to be kept up and it's got
it's got to be sustained to a certain
degree where you need one thing to
happen Budweiser apologizes yeah that's
it and until the apology don't buy bud
and so well yeah right when they when
they do apologize I say buy a bunch yeah
what what Market forecasters and
everybody needs to see is that when they
did this campaign with Dylan Mulvaney
their their stock drops their sales drop
and then as soon as they apologized goes
right back up yeah so so I should go up
even higher if they apologize I'll buy a
ton of beer I'm not gonna drink it but
you know but I think the other thing to
think think about is exactly what you
said what can you do
and it's not that you can give money to
cause you like what you can but you can
stop giving your money thing for example
you can stop giving your money to your
alma mater we have a project that was
sponsored called Don't donate where we
ask people the simplest ask in the world
don't donate your alma mater it's not
the same place you're you're pushing
woke ideology you're literally giving it
a kind of financial oxygen same thing
with Bud Light don't buy it any
companies that you've been donating to
or or working with check and see if
they've been bought lately because
there's been a lot of corporate
conglomeration in the last decade right
like Anheuser-Busch merged with some in
Bev yeah yeah and so now there's a bunch
of other brands Anheuser-Busch actually
really really big here's my favorite
Marjorie Taylor green tweeted out a
picture of buying cores and then some
leftist posted Coors woke campaign as
well right but here's my thing I don't I
don't care I do not care if Bud Light
what makes a pride can that's not what I
care about what I care about is Dylan
Mulvaney represents the algorithmic
crisis that is causing teenage
depression that is expanding and
creating wokeness in my view and then
they reward it not only that but Tick
Tock I believe is likely a trojan horse
you know the The Story Goes that in
China they get more controlled and
academic content and in the US it's all
weird woke stuff and people who think
they're frogs you know frog frog self
pronouns and stuff like that very
horrible ideas that are corrupting
people's brains and that Dylan Mulvaney
is is a perfect example of what those
algorithms do so when Bud Light dumps
money into that promotes it they're
actually making the algorithmic crisis
substantially worse so my my thing is
like get away from it don't don't fund
that stuff there's a lot of interesting
things that play here because there's
also the ESG score there's also fifth
generational Warfare we could go deep
down the rabbit hole when it comes to
explaining what's really going on here
but on a simple level I think if we
explain what just happened it was a
company trying to sell beer to quote
what they deemed a younger audience but
mainly a part of just preaching to a
woke religion that they were trying to
serve here and it's pretty clear that
they kind of forgot about their customer
base and a lot of people are discussing
hey what what beer should I drink here
what's next beer what's next next beer
should move on I think it's also
important to note here that even woke
people won't be buying uh Bud Light
because it's like you think we're that
simple where you could just put some
person on there and that's going to make
me want to buy your your fluoride filled
District No thank you I don't want that
bull crap anywhere near me it's an
endocrine disruptor and I think a lot of
people with the discussion that I would
love to have here to have a deeper
discussion maybe instead of replacing
your beer maybe maybe maybe let's let's
let's stay away from the move creating
endocrine disruptors that do of course
have a very negative effect on you and I
think this is a perfect time to start
that conversation being like hey don't
support this bull crap because it's bad
for you I don't drink yeah and how evil
do you have to be because the video of
this VP came out and she's talking about
we have to appeal to a younger younger
audience he has the rainbows behind her
what kind of evil person do you have to
be to say we're going to get young kids
hooked on beer and alcohol you are a low
vibrational like bad human being when
you're such a corporatist where you're
like we got to get all these people
hooked on alcohol
that's what she said peppered with woke
language throughout and so here's the
thing they're targeting college kids
they're targeting people who are under
the legal age to drink now and that
being said I think 18 should be the
legal drinking age I think it's
ridiculous they raised it to 21 in the
first place and I actually think beer is
actually pretty great
um I don't drink it the problem is abuse
not having some I might have a beer once
or twice a year to be completely honest
depending on the situation but it's not
going to be Bud Light because Bud
light's just it's like not really beer
it's kind of Castle if you're gonna try
it but there was even a Newcastle there
was even a new medical study that came
out showing that even moderate drinking
has very negative cognitive effects for
your brain and ages your brain and stops
blood flow to your brain there the moop
things is real there's there's a reason
Bill Gates has moops okay and it's not
accidental it's not a coincidence you're
saying he drinks too much beer oh that
and of course all the horrible
pesticides and byproducts there's also a
lot of glycopate in of course the beer
as well it's good to be back to get this
off of my chest
to finally be able to explain a lot of
this stuff because you know at the end
of the day here it is a corporation
trying to sell a product a product that
does have a lot of negative consequences
for people that should be the discussion
I think so let me ask you this question
I I maybe we can all agree I think
everybody would be better off if they
just drank water
you know that we actually do have
glasses over there sorry I didn't find
them so I'm using a measuring that's why
I like it hey it holds water that's good
now here's here's an important thing to
consider too for for this stuff the
reason why I really really am energized
in enervated by the story is Bud Light
deserves to lose money not just because
we disagree with the ideological
position of say you know Tick-Tock Dylan
Mulvaney or whatever
but light deserves to lose money because
this has to be one of the stupidest
business decisions
irrespective of wokeness in that
you've got people from the ages of 21 to
on average
79.3 years old
your your market share is 50 plus years
57 58 years and what they've done is
said we've got to get rid of the Frat
culture and appeal to a younger audience
so they're targeting people from the
ages of 21 to 25 in an effort to sell
beer at the expense of 25 to 80. and
they've got to understand the amount of
financial duress people are under that
are from the age of 21 to 25. young
people it's a constant theme on this
show and others that people don't have
money they don't have Direction the
school is too expensive they're in debt
like well they do have money but hold on
the money's being valued the money's
being devalued but but real quick and
that actually makes them smart but
they're targeting a segment of
population that doesn't have money
that's the weird thing that's actually a
good point you know it's funny because
they say when times are good people
drink when times are bad people drink
more and so right and so maybe they're
hoping like maybe the real Gambit here
is these young people are depressed and
listless they're gonna get drunk do you
think what better way to forget your
Sorrows what better way to live in your
pod and eat the bugs and of course if
you remember during covid the alcohol
industry skyrocketed that they were
allowed to have liquor stores that were
allowed to be open meanwhile the mama
pop stores weren't allowed to be open as
well so a lot of people drank a lot a
lot of people who are depressed drink a
lot and it makes a lot of emotional
issues a lot of emotional problems that
much worse for a lot of individuals so
when you're going after a key
demographic that still has a part of
their brain developing and you're saying
let's put booze in there come on let's
call let's call it out for what it is
here to me a lot of this is just
absolutely disingenuous I don't care I I
think there was just someone at Bud
Light saying we just need to make money
let's just let's just make as much money
as we can we don't care how we're going
to do it and then and then and then they
bring in the woke religion as a part to
be subservient see I was talking to
Vivek Rama Swami last week and this is
the where the conversation was going and
I I said I disagree what I think we're
seeing at these companies
they hire a 24 year old woman 10 years
ago she is a she's a marketing intern
two years later she's full-time staff
now she's uh you know a marketing
producer or something like that it's now
been a decade she fought her her boss 56
goes what's her name do you know her
name Luke
so so here's how I'm imagining he goes
Alyssa it's about time I retired I'm
about 60 some odd years let's say you
say I said he's in his 60s and he's like
I think this is a job you can handle and
she's like thank you so much and then as
soon as you walk outside she goes let's
sponsor Dylan Mulvaney and that's what
happened it there was there like there
are these people on the left that are
saying they did all this market research
they know exactly what they're doing I'm
like no no they don't yeah the people
who are woke who are ideologically
driven are not thinking logically about
numbers yeah they're thinking we are now
wearing the institution like a skin suit
let's Advance our cause I'm
automatically thinking of that Vice news
skit where they were taking
um adult
um toy employees and throwing them at
the wall randomly that could be it too
you never know this woman clearly is
woke though we saw yeah this video where
she has pronouns in her bio she's
peppering her language and I think that
the key thing is what you said Tim it's
that these people have intentionally
trained themselves not to think that all
of their information comes through a
funnel to promote wokeness but I guess
what I was thinking about have you heard
the the expression there's no such thing
as bad press yeah yeah this seems to
belie that there is bad press and bad
press can harm but I think the phrase
there's another thing is bad press
typically applies to an individual right
I think someone like Ben Shapiro has
actually greatly benefited from Bad
press but to be fair there's a
double-edged sword that comes along with
it in that
the bad press for an individual and for
a commentator they become more prominent
for someone like Ben Shapiro or for
anyone any of us here is that the more
they talk about you the more you become
the subject and the figure to be talked
about if you are Anheuser-Busch you are
on top of the mountain there's nowhere
else to go the only the only press
they're going to get is going to be
negative for their stock so bad press
bad for your stock individuals we don't
have stock so the more attention we get
the more we can capitalize on it for Bud
Light we'll put it I'll put it this way
they've got an opportunity when they
bring politics into beer which seems to
make no sense in my opinion for the most
part but when they this opportunity is
can we capture a large portion of one
demographic well my attitude is how
about you don't do any of it and you try
and just capture as much of the entirety
of people who drink beer by being a
neutral beer company as soon as they
enter the political Fray they segment
off a large portion of Their audience if
you are a political commentator or a
celebrity you're not gonna get a market
cap that is the entire population of the
planet
now imagine a company like Coca-Cola
Coca-Cola's market cap literally is
every human on earth except for maybe
like North Sentinel Island where they've
never made contact with people or
something like that so they have no
incentive whatsoever to be divisive and
bad press is bad if your market cap is
everyone
Coke Bud Light whoever else they want
everyone on the planet drinking their
product well go to war with one half of
them and you'll only lose customers if
you're a commentator and you're a
celebrity so who cares if 80 of the
world hates you 20 likes you and you'll
make money off them so bad bad all
around for Bud Light use it for us
something Peter I think you were
alluding that she they didn't seem to
know what they were doing is that what
you said earlier yeah what I think is
happening is that these folks and and
Alyssa has pronouns in her bio and she
Peppers all of her life so I would
encourage people to watch those videos
where she's explaining why she did this
they're not capable of independent
rational thought they're they're they
view themselves as white Knights who
promote the ideology this is a way to
promote her moral values and and within
that then she convinces herself that
well it would increase market share will
increase sales but it's just not true I
think it's the word inclusivity do we
have that video of Alyssa oh that video
is wonderful it's so great
it's incredible that she donated herself
like that but I guess everyone knew who
she was on the team anyway and the way
she says we need this we're looking to
do Inc I think it's the word inclusivity
inclusivity yeah something something and
an inclusive something something and
you're like why did she use the word
inclusivity twice she doesn't know what
it means that's why well that video that
you mentioned was from March 30th and
ever since I haven't seen much kind of
um any kind of words from Bud Light
afterwards after this oh that's from
okay yeah so that's from an earlier
video where she was explaining what she
was yeah and I wanna I wanna underscore
something Tim said that if you really
want to show that you can change and
make a difference it has to be sustained
able like you have to literally
continue to not buy the product until
they apologize and if you don't do that
then you're actually working against
your interest because companies are
going to keep doing this I don't think
an apology is enough they'll just issue
some crap they don't believe and then
try and the apologies everything the
apology is everything because you're
like making it okay because it's a
signal it's a costly signal it's a it
means they will if they issue an apology
that means Anheuser-Busch said the the
risk to our business from the far left
cult is less than the risk to our
business from pissing I see so you're
not trying that's a good point you're
not trying to destroy the company you're
trying to change the direction the
company takes yeah and we're not going
to be held hostage to to woke Maniacs
we're just not going to be held hostage
to these people let me pull up this
video here we have this video from uh
Chuck colesto it's a video of a guy uh
let's see if is the audio gonna play
so I don't I don't know is the audio
coming through give it to me Chuck
no audio's not coming through at all but
uh I'll just explain for you simply put
no it's just not coming through for you
I'm not seeing it on the I'm not hearing
it I'm not hearing it either and it's
not coming up on the thing
yeah so the audio audio is not playing
but that's fine that's fine there's a
video of a guy who's a distributor he
works for an affiliate company he says I
want to make sure I clarify that he's
got Bud Light on his arm at a liquor
store now this could be fake you know I
just want to make sure that's clear like
hard to verify just a random video on
the internet but this is just one of
several videos I've seen of people in
similar situations pointing out that
this the shelves are loaded with
Anheuser-Busch products and this guy
says that he works for an affiliate
company that only sells bud and Bud
Light products and he's never seen sales
this low which worries him because if we
don't sell these products I don't feed
my family like this is my company like
that I work for we got to do this yeah
and he goes so uh thanks Anheuser-Busch
maybe I won't feed my family I
definitely think it's a little
hyperbolic but we've seen a bunch of
these videos where people are reporting
on the ground that sales are dropping
we've seen the stock dropping and I
think it lines up and I think this
the left operates on lies and
manipulation I shouldn't say I don't say
all the left I want to say the woke cult
operates on lies and manipulation and so
they will twist anything as a victory
and they will twist anything you say
into something negative so here's what I
have to say
I'll be fully honest maybe these videos
are being faked by people who want to
make it seem like we're winning but I'll
just take it I look at their stock
prices their stock prices are way down
yeah so that's an independent metric
whereas the videos are not but all but
you know what if the stocks are dropping
and there's rumors of sale Decline and
then I see these videos I'm more
inclined to believe that these and other
videos I've seen are probably true
there's there's one video where it's
just a guy standing in a supermarket and
he just pans left and right and then you
see all the beers gone and then he pans
over and all the Budweiser products
still look we're in Austin why don't at
some point I'll go to a supermarket
Center why don't we just go to a
supermarket do it ourselves
yeah because I wonder if how pronounced
it is in a place like Austin yeah right
so so here's the other thing we're
hearing the guitar player from The
Offspring he countered Kid Rock and he
was like we're gonna stock all of our
shows with Anheuser-Busch products to
counter the bigots
it's like okay I mean this is
it is a bit silly I suppose but hey it's
a culture War for a reason I mean using
a guy that claims to be transgender to
sell your beer is a bit bigoted they're
like using Dylan Mulvaney it's not like
it's even worse to to use a guy to
Market tampons and sports bras
it's like using his identity it's so
just underhanded dirtiness to sell
product here's what I think I'll tell
you what I think Tick Tock my personal
opinion is it's not real my opinion has
never been that uh my opinion has always
been that it's not real and uh my
opinion Tick Tock bite dance whatever so
I said this a few years ago I explained
how a new social media platform can
emerge and I've actually talked to tech
companies about this here's what you do
create a nap then Market that app on
Instagram Facebook or wherever to uh
teenagers say the new cool app to do
this thing hire a bunch of young people
to do a fun thing like uh you know
singing songs then when they download it
and they make a post give them 150 likes
give them 50 new followers they're going
to respond to that positive
reinforcement and they're going to be
like whoa I got a bunch of new followers
you give them fake followers and
eventually all of these kids are going
to be like you still use Instagram
that's so lame why aren't you using you
know glabo and they're gonna be like
what what's that you're not on glabo
dude I Got 5 000 followers and then the
friend is gonna go you're 5 000
followers yeah I'm a big deal they're
gonna feel real good even though there's
no real humans behind that number but
that will convince their friends to get
on the platform as well you know it's
terrifying to me about that by the way
what's terrifying to me is I have
thought over the last few years that so
many things were conspiracy theories
that turned out to be not conspiracy
theories like all of them and now now
I'm listening well that's what what
happens when you're looking at it from
the other end of history and now I'm I'm
hearing this and I'm thinking you know
that's completely feasible yeah
especially with uh Quantum Computing on
the horizon and artificial intelligence
you could have a hundred thousand
followers that aren't real people that
are commenting actual things in response
to what you're doing the government have
been doing this for a very long time I
think the Israeli government was the
first one to come come out about it
publicly where they described whole
entire factories of people that were
online digital troll armies that were
specifically making sure that they were
engaging in debate and conversations
that made the Israeli government look
good Joe Biden just announced a whole
campaign for online influencers that are
going to be his influence Army for the
next 2024 presidential election so
obviously they're paying for PR using
our tax dollars to have people chill for
them who are just saying and doing
anything for a buck Dylan Mulvaney was
one of them yes and then wait wait hold
on Joe I saw this story this is the 50
Cent Army for the Democrats yes and
delmovania is going to be I don't know
if he's a part of it he was he went to
the White House yeah but as we know like
like Hillary Clinton hired influencers
high level influencers even someone I
don't think yes to specifically
endorsement hold on was he hired by them
there's different ways that of course
they conduct their businesses through
Pacs and different organizations so we
have to be careful with exactly how
we're wording here but I think it's fair
to say that money exchanged hands for
the support of this particular candidate
that money coming from of course either
super Pacs or our connections
organizations that's a bold actually but
when you have no no no no no in terms of
Casey neistat this one matters he was
he's the biggest vlogger he's not really
doing as much content as he used to he
came out and endorsed Hillary Clinton it
is my personal opinion that likely
constituted a monetary exchange from
someone or somehow because I don't see
how you get a dude who like films drones
and longboarding and and talking about
filmmaking all of a sudden coming out
and endorsing a politician in an
election but it's entirely possible he's
just going along with the crowd and
that's that's why it ended up happening
it might be connected or not connected
but how much was the CNN deal that's
also another one that also has a lot of
people looking at the situation like how
much money did he make what did he do
that I don't think he failed one the
whole thing didn't do anything so
there's multiple ways of of having
people show but for the spider
Administration to openly kind of discuss
how they're going to be
taken and giving money to people to
chill for them I mean that's going to
make everyone question like wait are you
really in support of this person or are
you just being paid to support this
person look I I
when I go out into normal places you
know if you're in DC you're going to be
around a bunch of people who are hyper
political but when I go out to the
movies when I go to pool pool halls when
I go to the poker club or whatever I
have not met a single person who was Pro
Biden
like pro-democrat I don't see them
anywhere and you know of course if I say
something like that I'm gonna do a bunch
of left as being like haha go touch
grass but like dude
I've not seen it anywhere I you know I
go I go to uh we've been going to
Maryland Live a casino
playing uh Hold'em one two super super
inexpensive for those that that are
considering playing it's like you pay
two bucks to play a hand so it can be
played cheaply and uh out of all the
tables I've played at and this is north
of DC south of Baltimore I have not met
a single pro-democrat person in this
major urban center where it's just
regular people hanging out from various
ages young guys to older guys well how
do you know does it come up at the table
absolutely every time every time without
fail someone mentions the cost of the
game or the economy and then immediately
oh Joe Biden Joe Biden he's bad now
don't get me wrong I met a guy who said
he thought the j6er should be executed
and he hated Donald Trump dead I get but
I've not met anybody who was like I like
this guy now that could be these people
voted for him and now they really really
do regret it is it a blue area it's the
bluest as blue can be
I mean it's it's we're talking about
Baltimore and Maryland and and uh this
casino is I think it's I don't know what
city it's in it's it's 30 minutes from
downtown Baltimore it's like half an
hour from DC orbital it's right in
between so everybody who's going there
it's people from the cities who are
trying to you know play a game or
whatever
so I I I I kind of feel like at this
point the the reasoning for why Biden's
building a 50 Cent Army is fairly
obvious I do not see them being able to
pull off another Victory I'm seeing all
these polls where they're like Biden is
beating Trump in these states Biden is
beating Trump and I'm like don't care
don't believe it I mean look ballot
harvesting may come to save the day but
it's clear that they're going to be
ramping up what I would describe as
unethical and malicious tactics in the
election and the idea of of a Democrat
so so for those who don't know the 50
Cent Army what is it in China anybody
who Pro posts on social media Pro CCP
propaganda they get paid 50 cents every
time they do or something like that
so this is basically what we're going to
start seeing with Democrats and that's
probably what's already happening so
we're talking about anheuser-boys we're
talking about Dylan Mulvaney and the
algorithmic manipulation
that is what the Democrats are riding
that wave
yeah the the thing you didn't say which
I think needs to be said which speaks to
your point is what this does to the
Integrity of the system overall this is
what causes a legitimacy crisis right so
we don't trust our institutions we now
think the people we like on social media
they're being paid certain I've never
taken a single penny for anything but
Twitter feed anything I think that that
compromises the Integrity but when you
do that in a political level it's
terrifying to me
it's terrifying absolutely and
especially when you connect it to
something like a social credit score
which they do in China because if you
complain about the government in China
you of course get downranked with your
social credit score you can't get
high-speed internet you can't travel on
airplanes you have you can't buy first
class tickets on trades and that's being
tested in China which they're trying to
roll out and bring out here in the
United States as there's already a
corporate social credit score that no
one really likes to talk about it's not
a government institution but the
corporate social credit score and
everyone here already exists there is an
ESG score with the corporations but
there's even another one with each
Citizen and civilian with all of your
private records especially from social
media being uh compiled together and
then soon going to be used against you
later what's that called is that a
program they're doing no there's many
different corporations keep them private
records and they sell all these private
records about you and your itinerary and
what you do and what you like what you
dislike your views your opinions all of
that is databased so there's huge
databases being built about particular
individuals those again are are being
used by the corporations they're being
used by the government women in China
and then that's where they're testing
the 15-minute cities so if you say
something bad well your 15-minute City
might be a five minute City and they're
already locking down grids they're
already testing it they're doing a trial
run of that in the United Kingdom
there's a lot of crazy stuff Honolulu
explain the difference what is 15 minute
what does five minute mean well this is
the restrictions that they're setting up
pretty much essentially prisons pretty
much essentially lockdowns they did this
in China and they tested it during covid
they locked down entire communities
because they said they had a positive
case but what a lot of people are saying
that this was most likely a larger test
to see how these 15-minute cities would
work because they would lock down entire
neighborhoods and say you're going to be
you can't move between this street and
this street you can't go between here
and here they tested it out in Australia
where people were fined and arrested for
going from one city block to another
city block because they were going
through an imaginary line in
jurisdiction so a lot of people say that
that was a dry testing of this larger
concept which is essentially prison
grids uh internal systems where you
can't move around anywhere but 15
minutes within it and you get everything
you ever wanted right the idea is that
within 15 minutes of your home you can
get access to anything you would need
correct yeah hospitals supermarkets
entertainment movies whatever it is it's
all confined here and you better not go
around this is again to dance and fight
people from driving de-incentivize
people for having personal Liberty track
trace and database of society of total
control grid the world of information
knowing every little thing about you and
then that information being used against
you in every way and if you're not a
part of the 50 Cent Army well your your
ability to move around is going to be
limited a lot more because the
checkpoints are already there they're
digital and they have cameras and and
facial recognition and all right they're
setting it up
I just wanna I wanna say something you
know there's a viral video we talked
about it's really funny it's where a guy
says he wants to show you a perfect
example of a 15-minute scene how it
works and then he walks up this little
shed and he says let me show you a 50
Cent sitting when he opens it up
chickens and he goes welcome to a
15-minute City he walks inside and says
here the citizens have everything they
could hope for now they could go outside
if they want look the door's open they
don't want to leave it's safe in here
there's no danger they have food they
have water it's always there for them
and then he walks into another room and
he goes you see this instead of grabbing
eggs and he goes they make these and I
take them from them but that's okay
they're happy because they're safe in
their 15-minute City so he made a really
great point and I want to make a point
on top of that could you imagine if you
went to your chicken coop one day to
collect chickens and a bunch of roosters
pulled out guns and pointed them at you
and said you're not taking the eggs this
time you'd be like what how did these
chickens have guns and then you go I'm
like we gotta take these guns away well
we can't like the chickens have guns and
you're like I don't know how they're
even using them and then you got to
figure out how do you disarm the
chickens if if they're armed and they
can fight back you can't take for them
you can't imprison you can't control
them they can they're unequal footing
with you obviously chickens don't have
guns my point is if someone is trying to
control you and you have the means of
telling them no they cannot Implement
their authoritarian fascist takeovers
and that's what we've seen throughout
history when despots and fascists try to
take over yeah guns make it very
difficult that was one of the impetus of
the an emphasis of the Second Amendment
you know and that's why they're doing
this in China they did this in China
they're doing this in the United Kingdom
they did this in Australia during covert
right now in Oxford specifically in the
United Kingdom they're doing the trial
run for the 15-minute cities blocking
people from traveling one road to
another all in the name of
sustainability it's not sustainability
it's enslavement sorry go ahead no I'm
just going to say if you look at the
world economic economic performance that
are the data it's not framed as a
conspiracy it's not framed to manipulate
to control its frame to be sustainable
that's the approach that they use it's
sustainable to have farm animals to
treat human beings like they have no
dignity no individual human spirit and
they can't live on their own then they
need to be dictated what they can and
cannot do or believe in or think and
that's essentially this larger notion
this larger elitism of individuals
thinking that they have the right and
they're they're doing this in so many
instances that are so bastardized that
are so disgusting they think that they
have the right to to control what goes
into your head to control what you see
what you hear and they're doing this
with big Tech social media already in so
many different ways trying to engineer
people to be perfect Lemmings to be
perfect slaves to acquiesce to bow down
and to take it and I think people who
are paying attention had enough of this
bullcrap all right you guys ready for
this one let's jump to this next story
from the post-millennial FBI Flags slang
terms Chad based red pilled it's over to
Target racially motivated violent
extremists the FBI's domestic terrorism
reference guide on involuntary celibate
violent extremists offer a threat
overview for in cells that aim to
identify them by the slang they use
so uh you thought Biden's 50 Cent Army
was bad yeah you're gonna have a whole
bunch of crackpot well cultists getting
paid to promote Democrats now the feds
are going to be targeting you if you say
things like based and that's one of the
reasons your former guest Vivek wants to
eliminate the FBI one of the many
reasons he wants to eliminate the effort
I love that I'm like wow this guy's he's
pretty hardcore you know Ron Paul was
saying that many decades ago he was
saying that 30 years ago and I think
there's individuals even before that at
the very beginning of the FBI they have
a horrible record especially with J.R
Hoover especially with what they did to
JFK what they did to MLK what they did
to Malcolm X the the what they did with
MK Ultra holy cow if you look at this
agency there needs to be some oversight
there needs to be some accountability
there was just a new disclosure
happening with the proud boys trial with
January 6th and it people just found out
that out of the 13 proud boys eight of
them were paid FBI informants five of
them are being prosecuted so so that
that's more federal agents that took
part of January 6th a part of The Proud
boys than the actual proud boys which is
crazy
those are insane numbers and then
they're hiding and and making sure that
they're spying on the defense I mean
what's happening with the January 6 case
is just a notion of what's going to be
happening to everyone unless we we
address this and stop it so this is a
very post-modern notion the idea that
that power is everywhere and you can use
words and they've done so incredibly
they've been incredibly effective at
this you can use words to change the
culture you can use words and I mean
think about that red pill I mean these
are not the n-word they're not even
remotely close to it these are words
that indicate a condition oh you know
from The Matrix but it's not that it's
it's a it's a reference to being part of
a subculture and if the FBI thinks based
or Chad
racially motivated extremes the left
uses base too exactly there are seven
words all together it was based red pill
blue pilled Normie Chad LARPing and
incel if that if that's the criteria
you're using WOW
but leftists use LARPing substantially
more than people on the right do do
claim that the right is live-action
role-playing their fantasies this is a
big problem that with the FBI is having
as they're Downstream from social media
from the technology and all this data
can be spoofed like if Facebook wants to
tell the FBI that you said something you
didn't say they can and they can make it
look like you did in the software even
the idea that we live in the United
States and then this is an issue at all
is insane that is another reason why
there's a legitimacy crisis nobody
trusts the institutions anymore it's
because it's a global Community now like
we live in the US but this this Global
governance it's here now we can say like
it's coming but it's here now like it's
the it is one UNA government that's
right it's a corruption so in your face
though when you have a moment in time in
history where you say Chad you're going
to be investigated by the FBI right if
you say it online you say in cell you
say red pill you go to Epstein Island
you're on The Client List of Mr Epstein
FBI's like yeah you're clear you're good
don't worry about that how in the world
are we allowing the Federal Bureau of
Investigations that by the way the doj
FBI had an investigation on Epstein they
never released the findings of that
investigation they have The Client List
they have the videos they have the
pictures of very powerful people doing
some very horrible things
I mean if you know if you were on some
dude's Island and then you were asked to
investigate yourself you wouldn't
release the list either that's true good
point very good point there so yeah so
yeah I imagine that's likely the
circumstance I think uh why are we
letting people do this because people
haven't stepped up to build systems that
are resilient to this kind of behavior
so it's going to happen we need systems
that are encrypted where we control
locally our own our own system we need
to be able to govern ourselves locally
um as best as possible when you start
building systems like that that are not
untrackable but challenging to track I
think you're in a better play where the
code's readable the issue is the the FBI
the doj have gone after anybody who
makes encrypted Communications I feel
like they're afraid that there's going
to be some sort of Revolt or like
revolution in the states I hadn't heard
that I encrypt everything oh yeah I mean
aside from the fact that they've
probably cracked a whole lot of the
encryption telegram the Russian
government has attacked a cracked
telegram they're investing people who
com who well let me let me complain
about the Russian war I'll just ask you
something very simple who do you think
has more cyber resources a private
company or a nation-state if we're talk
it obviously it depends on the nation
state right you know I think Chiquita
bananas had a good hold over what was it
uh what countries was it Nicaragua I
don't know I don't think it was Costa
Rica
um but anyway I digress we're talking
about Russia and their military
capabilities in terms of cyber warfare
pretty sure they're gonna have more
resources than Telegram and they're
going to have a capability to either
crack telegram encryption or simply put
go to the people who run it and then say
here's what you're going to do or else
you know maybe the CEO of some company
goes out for his uh pick up his
newspaper in front of his apartment when
a black van pulls up guys throw a bag
over his head throw him in they drive
off nobody knows it happened and then he
wakes up in a dark room and they're like
you're going to give us a back door to
all of your encryption or else and they
go whatever you say and that's exactly
what happened to Lava bit and the
founder of lava bit I I interviewed the
guy it was Edward snowden's email
service that he was using the feds came
to him and says give us everything on
Edward Snowden or else and then he I
believe he printed out a hundred pages
of the password uh in very small font
and then gave it to the FBI legally
complying with them and they had to
manually put in the long password to the
encryption and then when they were doing
that I think he deleted the server shut
the whole company down shut the whole
company down and then and then this is
why you know this is like in China this
is almost exactly what's happening in
China but here we just have a different
face on it and and the more we don't
understand this reality the more we kind
of hinder ourselves because when we look
at Facebook when we look at YouTube when
we look at you know as we found out from
Twitter we're not looking at private
entities and private corporations we're
looking at government hand inside of the
business directing not only who gets to
say whatever whatever they want to say
who gets to see it why they get to see
it who gets promoted who gets demoted
that right there is the power to control
people's minds and that's the power that
they're wielding every single day and
people need to realize it more than ever
this story that came out a few weeks ago
or like a week and a half ago that Elon
Musk said they were qualifiers coded
into the Twitter system that would
identify you as a Democrat a Republican
or a VIP
or Elon Musk which was funny and weird
that he had his own special category of
like this is Elon he's tweeting but they
would label you a Democrat or Republican
like they had that in their system and
people were calling that out how much do
you want to bet that if you had the
Democrat tag yeah that was okay that you
said that thing about those kids when
that guy posts the the picture of the
wood chipper with blood coming out
during the Covington kid incident I
wonder if he had one of those tags on it
and they're like he's okay
so the thing that's been running through
my mind through this conversation is
let's say that somebody who doesn't
listen to you Tunes in Tim
it's so hard to break through to people
when you show stories like this or when
you talk about
scores or when you talk about because
they'll just think you're a conspiracy
theory lab leak conspiracy so how do we
the thing that I've been thinking about
for quite a while is how do we reach
these people like what is it that we can
say or how do we
convey this in a way that makes them
think
I'll put myself in script we are not
conspiracy theorists when we talk about
this oh this is funny I mean look we we
I use newsguard certification for all
the sources we use
I know news guard's not good I know
they're biased they attacked us and then
put a bunch of lies about timcast.com we
still end up getting a near we end up
getting a near perfect score they they
gave us a strike out of you know out of
like 10 we got one because we quoted
Donald Trump that's it that's all we did
yeah we ran a story Donald Trump said
this they went oh nope nope that's fake
news and I'm like all we're doing is
quoting a guy but I digress the point is
when I try and talk to people who are as
I describe uninitiated I'm not going to
come out right away and start talking
about barisma and Ukraine and all this
really crazy stuff I'll take it really
really light and be like yeah that the
Trump impeachment wasn't that that was
um what was it there's that video of Joe
Biden saying that he was threatening to
withhold congressionally approved Aid
which was illegal or something like that
real light approach and then if they say
what I've I don't know anything about
that I'll be like oh here I'll show you
and then you just pull up a NPR or some
other news source and be like I don't
know read it you tell me what you think
I I usually take that approach I'll say
here's the story what do you think yeah
I have the opposite approach I I just go
right over the head satanic child
let's just go there I think different
people have different ways of of you
know of approaching this information but
I think first of all the conversation
needs to be started we're doing it I
agree the conversation starts with the
people who are listening the people who
are taking notes to people who are
studying because you guys need to be
informed more than ever and it it's it's
it's it's the game's rigged on social
media the game's rigged here the game's
rigged everywhere online but it's not in
real life this is why again I'm not just
trying to be a shill here but I've been
a big proponent of t-shirts I've been a
big proponent of people talking to their
family members their friends and I think
that is more imperative than ever of
individuals doing their homework doing
their research and whether it's having a
light-hearted kind of approach of
empathy whether it's hitting them over
the head with just the bigger truths
going down the rabbit hole who knows
what will work but I think being uh
Brave and and being able to have those
conversations is the first step that we
need to have but but the other thing too
is
outside of all of that there's a real
simple way to win it's called voting
with your dollars so shout out to our
friends at Public Square download the
Public Square app they've sponsored the
show before but this is a freebie
because I really do believe in what
they're doing it's an app that shows you
businesses that have taken a pledge to
support American values so you can make
sure you're giving your money to
companies that that believe in the good
and then uh don't buy anything from
Anheuser-Busch and don't donate to your
alma mater please yeah yeah uh Will
Chamberlain like to say I don't know if
he still does I'm assuming he just seize
the endowments yep and that's one of the
things that we're doing at my non-profit
National progress Alliance do not it
should be the easiest ask in the world
don't donate by the way just I
personally don't like the hardcore
approach so I'll ask people I'll say
something like which is true I don't
know if you guys were I don't want to go
down this rabbit hole but I personally
was due by the hunter Biden laptop story
I thought it was a plant I get I'm
betting you guys didn't I jury's out I
mean I can't wait for facts and improve
roof and I want proof three times before
I start to accept something Luke Luke
probably went completely in the other
direction yeah yeah and then I was
probably in the middle like let's figure
out where this came from yeah so the way
that I try to reach people is I'll say
you know I like I'll put it on myself I
fell for that what were you thinking
about that oh or I and then I'll say
well which is also true I didn't really
know whether or not it was a lab leak
hypothesis but the lab League hypothesis
too but all these people said people who
were in Authority people who were
supposed to be trusted I believe them
and I was wrong in other words like I
was wrong maybe they were wrong but what
about this like what about this so if
you can undermine their confidence in
things in the past they can make their
own conclusions about whether or not I
think the best thing you do is be
genuine and if you believe something say
you actually believe in those things and
I think living your life as an example
being like hey I don't do this I don't
support this I don't want my money going
towards this I don't want to spend my
time investing in these really bad
people that are connected to these
really awful people with these chemicals
and this thing and I think and and and
again it's all personable so if you're
seeing someone who's very kind of
sensitive who's very kind of introvert
you obviously don't do my method you
obviously use Tim's method but if you
see someone who is is is you know
open-minded someone eager obviously you
just beat him over the head straight
down the rabbit I like to steal man the
opposition I kind of take that role on
this show a lot of times people in the
audience think I'm like an idiot but
like I will act as if we are wrong and I
will give you yeah it's it's so
important to do that and it's also so
unfortunate that you have to it's so
unfortunate that woke people will not
have conversations with you they will
not engage in discussion Smart Ones
understand why they can't well be a
hundred percent because they they have
no it's such a banker bankrupt ideology
and the people forwarding it have
profoundly mediocre Minds well it's not
that it's that there is no ideology
so what do you mean so I mean this is my
consistent position on what wokeness is
wokeness is the modern left liberal
culture formulated by social media
algorithms it is characterized by
cult-like adherence to Liberal social
Orthodoxy that's all it is and the
example of this is Ukraine why woke
people support a war and Ukraine makes
literally no sense it doesn't follow any
academic theories okay so let's we I
think we have to unpack it have you have
you read Tim Urban you know Tim Urban
the weight but why what's our problem no
but you you were mentioning it before
this is like one of the best books I've
ever read but in chapter five about
social justice he has a chart I think we
we sent you that chart um if you could
pull it up great but he talks about I I
do think it's a coherent ideology yeah
there it is from Tim Urban's weight but
why
blogger which are a problem
it's fascinating how it originates in
Marxism goes down the tree to critical
theory this is the best book since the
2020 cynical theories by Helen pluck
Rosen James Lindsay on this topic in my
opinion uh and you have he talks about
social justice fundamentalism at one end
and liberal social justice I think you
and I I think everybody in this room
frankly falls on the side of liberal
social justice not equality of outcome
equality of opportunity not using race
to divide but being what what is now a
microaggression colorblind to people we
make those judgments I do think that
there's a fundamental core tenant or
there are fundamental core tenants of
the ideology and so racism is everywhere
it's baked into the system there's
whiteness but your privilege seeks to
preserve itself I mean etc etc and that
is a component of what wokeness is but
it's also just when I when I try to
Envision wokeness as an object it is
like a Jackson Pollock painting yeah it
is but that's because wokeness isn't
denied ideology it is it is not this
thing these things uh they frustrate me
when I see and and I think this is this
this chart is probably correct uh you
know going from post-modernism down and
critical race Theory intersectionality
but it applies an academic world view
into the modern problem which has
already been shown by mult uh numerous
data points including there was the Zach
Roberts Lexus Nexus Twitter threat from
a few years ago that all around the same
time everywhere in the world the same
thing happened where there was a massive
spike in the same Concepts ideas words
and what likely happened is and I'll put
it this way the reason why I don't
believe we're dealing with an ideal
ideology of the left we're dealing with
algorithmic corruption is that Jack
Dorsey was not woke until he started
eating the own refuse of his own social
media platform okay so can we spend some
time on this because I think that's
really important okay so this is the
frame that I suggest thinking about this
at the top you have Theory
below that you have institutions and
downstream from that you have
individuals beliefs so 2017 we had this
almost this exact conversation yeah a
very heated debate I would call it
Lively I thought it was great no I
thought it was great too I thought it
was fantastic with with James and Helen
in the room so
so at the level of theory you have what
we tried to do with so-called squared if
the grievance studies hoax we tried to
undermine the theory we tried to show
that it's bogus we tried to attack it
what Reid and I are going around the
world doing Street epistemology is to
show so that it goes from the theory to
the institutions the institutions to the
people the institutions the academies
K-12 and we can talk about that more
than happy to talk about that our
academic institutions you get promoted
and tenure based upon the papers you you
write usually seven papers in seven
years unless you you write something
that's morally fashionable it's very
difficult to get published and we're
going to do the University of San
Francisco story I hope because I think
that this encapsulates it perfectly
educational administrators themselves
participate in the ideology so there's a
structure
and so so when you say algorithms I want
to say two things that are important
about this the woke people occupy the
very so they get their degree five six
seven years later they go out they
become administrators they become
managers Etc they bring the madness that
they took with them that they think it's
true based upon what they perceive to be
legitimate bodies of literature
microaggressions trigger warnings safe
spaces belonging Equity all this
nonsense they take that with them and
they institutionalize that we can cover
it if you want but it's a reverse Trojan
Horse Martin Bailey we can cover that so
now to get to your point about the
algorithms yes you are correct but the
algorithms themselves wouldn't even make
sense unless you understood that model
like this doesn't come X neolo like Mana
from heaven right so it comes at a very
specific place I'm starting to think
that institutions include social media
networks now hold on the first uh one of
the first big political Trends was
probably Loose Change 911 which was
certainly not within the confines of
this Academia and the Ron Paul
Revolution which was absolutely not in
the confines of this Academia what what
happens is
you see what I believe it is that humans
have tendencies
uh rage make someone more likely to
share something than any other emotion
anger and I always shout out cgp's gray
cgp Gray's video this video will make
you angry and he explains this and he
was like it's really great he's like
this group is talking about the other
group the other group's talking about
this group they're actually talking to
each other they're talking about each
other and he's like trust me I am not
talking about your group
so what I see here is yes the ideologies
of the left do exist and they do have a
degree of prominence among the modern
left today but there's also I don't know
how many how many ideologies exist 100
000 countless Millions countless so why
is it that this is the one I think the
issue is that's a genealogical question
that I that I could answer but I I don't
think uh uh the chart the chart actually
answers that but right but this chart
then omits every other ideology and the
path that's taken and it's degree of
prominence but every other ideology
isn't the dominant moral Orthodoxy now
this is the dominant moral Orthodoxy we
see it everywhere and it's because of
social media algorithms not because of
University okay okay so that's the
question that's question why are the
social media algorithms catering to the
moral Orthodoxy they they're so very
simply put advertisers fund moral
Orthodoxy before wokeness took over how
did this begin first we had in what was
it what year was it Luke 2008 2009 the
Ron Paul Revolution right around there
yep you're starting to see the emergence
of moral of of moralizing through social
media with people listening to Ron
Paul's message and it resonating to the
point where they were going around
slapping stickers everywhere
anti-intervention sound currency a lot
of really really awesome things that I
completely agree with today but
eventually
these social media platforms started to
adopt algorithms that would show you
more of what you engaged with two things
happen people people are more likely to
share something that makes them angry
and advertisers are less likely to
advertise on something that's morally
objectionable in modern culture at the
time 2008 we find racism to be
objectionable so a big Advertiser says I
don't want my product on racist content
yeah we we okay so you just smuggled
something in there we find it to be
objectionable because
this is morally fashionable like this is
what's morally fashionable today but
this was
yeah I guess the the main wokeness
really kicked in 2012 2010 so 2008 I
would give its pre-wokeness but you're
talking in that case you're talking
about kind of tribalism right you're not
talking about the algorithms themselves
do they feed outrage for sure yes yeah
for sure every single thing you've said
is true
and it's I don't mean to use a big word
but it's the only word to describe it's
covariant like both of those variables
act upon each other at the same time to
enforce the dominant moral Orthodoxy
even more than it was in the first place
so what's happening is this is why I say
that the problem is not the ideology the
ideologies existed for a long time the
ideology is a component of the problem
the problem is we are in a feedback loop
of algorithms quadrupling upon
quadrupling our problem it's exponential
growth so the example of this I give is
2008 it starts with the viral Ron Paul
Revolution which is a good thing then
you start to see my favorite example is
mic.com which started off as a website
exploiting this and they were producing
libertarian content however within that
libertarian content was anti-police
brutality content because Libertarians
didn't like that either there was also
Second Amendment audits that were going
viral where people were alike the cop
stop mean you get these videos of people
challenging police officers right then
people start adding in a racial
component why because they start putting
up video of police brutality against
black people
these videos start getting and start
getting just plastered all over Facebook
because it makes money at one point a
website that was dedicated to nothing
but police brutality videos was the
400th most viewed website in the world
I'm not going to say what website that
was and uh they were paying their
writers an exorbitant amount of money
and all they did was post videos of
police brutality this starts fracturing
the minds of 10 year olds in 2010 who
are now 23 year olds who are voting in
this election whose entire world view
has been built upon a machine that
started with libertarian Advanced into a
so here's what happens when Libertarians
are sharing anti-police content and
they're getting a lot of views because
people don't like Injustice it is the is
the epitome of Injustice when a cop
violates our rights like that's that's
the op that's supposed to be upholding
the law then you add in a racial
component and now you have an
exponential growth the people who hate
racism and the people who like who hate
police brutality everyone's seeing it
and everyone's sharing it then mike.com
shifts its business model and says this
gets more views let's do more of this
instead the company then slowly rather
exponentially rapidly shifts into a woke
social justice company but here's the
thing when this happened we didn't have
the word woke I mean sort of it it was
it was here and there what was the word
intersectional feminist which then gave
rise to social justice and social
justice Warriors I mean at first it was
feminism then it was intersectional
feminism then the then the sjw then we
ended up with the complaints about
critical race Theory then people pointed
out actually critical gender theories in
there too and now it's woke what we're
seeing is a feedback loop of social
media algorithms funneling refuse back
into the mouths of people and what I
would only describe as a human centipede
of ideology just to clarify would you
say that woke is the way that the
ideology is funneled
so when people say
what does woke even mean okay well when
when the average person describes woke
they may mean a bunch of different
things but the one unifying factor is
they're referring to the modern left
liberal Orthodoxy that was created by
social media algorithms
and the example I give is
Ukraine war is the is the easiest way to
understand this why is it that Hassan
will be like here are these things
that I believe trans rights and then
also I also am for war in Ukraine and
you're like what did these things have
to do with each other and why is it that
this individual has no principles it's
just
he just follows the Orthodoxy you think
there's a woke on the on the other side
of the coin like for people right wing
version but it's so small and there's no
institutional power behind it I find it
to be negligible but it could become it
could become a problem if it were let I
think it was white nationalism yeah I
think that the anti-wo people are
starting to use some of the tools of the
walk now so it's and I want someone to
come back to what you said because I
think it's important uh you know
cancellation or not having conversations
with people with whom they disagree so I
think that they're adopting the tools to
buttress the ideology
this is both a very complicated problem
and a non-complicated problem so I don't
mean to muddy the waters too much but I
do want to say this because it's been
really bumming me out so I read a piece
in the epistemology of democracy it was
about by a key stanovic it was about my
side bias and my side bias this will
horrify you and hear it but my side bias
is exactly what you think it would be my
side is right your side is wrong but
this the the article or the chapter in
the book argued that there's literally
nothing you can do to overcome my sibis
no training no education nothing but
when you combine that
um that research chapter with what you
just said not only can you not do
there's no amount of Education that can
get over my side by us you're now
talking the algorithm being held hostage
to the algorithm yes
by the humans so even if you're right so
even if there weren't the case that
you're being held hostage by the
algorithm you're still suffering you
know this my side bias thing no training
no education Etc you just can't so what
are you gonna do so that is I think what
is often missing in these conversations
would I just like to throw in there we
know there's a problem we've been
talking you and I have been talking for
years we know this is a problem and I
think when people are hungry for now is
what are we going to do about it what's
the psychedelics you said one you said
one thing right we're going to stop
donating to Alma Mater we're going to
stop buying you know we're going to vote
with our dollars if you will but I think
what would be helpful I think to a lot
of your viewers is ending every one of
these sessions these conversations with
what are you going to do about like
empowering them to do something and so
obviously that's why I wanted to lead
with the Anheuser-Busch story because it
seems like this is particularly
effective let me tell you I've got these
tweets that I love to tweet where I say
something like sterilize your children
to prevent overpopulation right it's a
joke right or I'll say something about
uh leftists will abort their children or
sterilize their children
and then I had one tweet where I said
and this is a good thing because it
stops overpopulation and humans are
causing climate change not one time has
any publication ever criticized me or
written about those tweets
yet when I say don't buy beer I get 500
articles saying far right fascist
outraged whiny loser because you can
tell what's working they don't want to
bring up the fact that they're aborting
their kids and sterilizing them because
that's bad for them in the long run but
if they highlight that they have to
point out the things we're promoting are
detrimental and deleterious to our
ideology and then when I say something
like don't buy beer they're like quick
we got to put a stop on stop to that not
only is it affecting our ad our
potential sales because we're sponsored
by this company
but there's there's there's truth the
fact that if Budweiser sales do drop and
they are forced to apologize
that will be a major shift in the
culture War the moment a massive
multinational corporation says we are
sorry for being woke woke people will
lose their minds because that means
we're sorry we made a genuine mistake we
wish we hadn't done it we have we'd like
to get you back and then and that's and
and real quick Netflix never apologized
for Cuties and they still have big mouth
but when they started getting rid of
some of the woke uh shows and stuff they
had and they talked about it they saw a
subscriber increase so they're probably
learning an important lesson but the
apology is everything you said earlier
real quick just one last point
antifa uses violence and the far left
uses violence and in the Summer of Love
they got away with it because they have
law enforcement to a certain degree on
their side either because police are too
feckless or the DA's are bought and paid
for so these big companies as I've long
stated do not fear Dave Rubin classical
liberals showing up with pitchforks they
do fear antifa who do it and get away
with it if Budweiser is willing to make
an apology to all of us for sponsoring
Dylan Mulvaney that means they are
saying the threat of physical force from
antifa is not as scary as us actually
going out of business yeah and I want to
I want to add to that and I want to just
say that the people listening to this
one of the things that I've seen over
and over again is people are very afraid
to piss off the far left my comment to
you is they already hate you they
already hate you because you're going to
say something are not toe the line
perfectly do not be afraid of these
people do not be held hostage to them be
based also the cartels and Islam don't
be held a hostage to Violent extremists
of any kind no offense people not Islam
at all but I mean you know what's his
name um Richard Dawkins was afraid to
even criticize or talk about it that's
really sad
should be criticized shout out to
Stephen Crowder potentially one of the
most Fearless guys who's constantly
making jokes and saying Fu to all of
these extremists were telling them to
shut up you said earlier how could these
things could cause people to lose their
minds these far left and you were saying
this my side bonus I actually jokingly
said psychedelics but like I think being
able to clear your mind helps you see
the the danger of your side like if it
means that recording yourself on video
uploading it and watching yourself say
it and having no choice but to accept
that's what you are you'll see what you
did wrong let me uh the psychedelics you
got to do what's legal and what's safe
for you but being able to clear your
mind whether through fasting I think it
helps you helps you see the crap on your
side let's let's jump to the story from
timcast.com
female swimmer assaulted by trans
activists while speaking on women's
rights quote this is proof that women
need sex protected spaces so you may
have seen the story this is about Riley
Gaines she is a woman's rights activist
I guess you'd call that a feminist who
has taken issue with with males
competing in female sports right she was
going to be speaking at an event and a
mob of far-left extremists chased her
into a room and then what they pinned
her down for about three hours demanded
Ransom yeah they said make them pay us
pay us money that's extortion I guess
look at what happened with Brett
Weinstein and Evergreen yeah when they
were mocking and holding these
administrators hostage it's not the
first time yeah and if anybody doesn't
know the bread story which you should
either watch the Jordan Peterson or the
Mike Nana has a wonderful coverage of
that actually a long time ago produced a
miniature documentary well good at
Evergreen with Brett and so uh you can
you can search for Brett Weinstein
Evergreen Tim cast or something I want
you on the show Brett if you're
listening so so what was the latest
development here with Riley game oh so
what I wanted to talk about is is this a
story I had no question about it but
this kind of stuff this is an extreme
but it happened to Charles Murray I mean
it happens it happens all the time
what's really the story to me which
really the story is what the university
did they said that they were peaceful
protests they offered them counseling
they said transphobia has no place in
the university the statement if you
could pull the statement up it's an
utterly remarkable it's it's opposite
land and this is what is happening in
our universities and this is why
it's so important to talk about this
it's again what I had mentioned this is
the legitimacy Christ This is a crisis
of legitimacy institutions and this is
contributing to that this is the misuse
of the word phobia that's for sure
because saying that you don't want
biological men to compete in physical
sports with biological females or
doesn't mean you're afraid of trans or
women's prisons yeah it's not that
you're afraid of it I mean I'm not
afraid I just I'm concerned maybe and
it's not like this person's saying
anything radical he's crazy she's she's
just making logical political points
that that are are not out of the
ordinary and to have a group of people
chase her down to physically assault or
I mean I was chased by you know some of
these mobs before I was assaulted by one
of these mobs before it's not fun to
deal with but the police officers here
to cower not do anything here in the
university to back that it is here it is
a deranged statement and anybody who
reads that if you ever had any question
whatsoever that the academies are
ideologically captured read their
statements well so they New York crosses
some of it they say following the Mayhem
Jamila Moore vice president for student
affairs and enrollment management
emailed students thanking them for
taking part in the event it took
tremendous bravery to stand in a
challenging space I am proud of the
moments where we listened and asked
insightful questions I am also proud of
the moments when our students
demonstrated the value of free speech
and the right to protest peacefully
welcome to the modern area you see what
they did Free Speech right you see how
they chased her into a room demanded
money threatened her life right
and they framed it under free speech
that's what they do
is someone playing something or
something
yeah I think someone's downstairs on the
phone can you tell them their phone if
that's okay and that they're um yeah I
was I was actually just communicating
with Serge I missed the top part of the
quote that they said but they were happy
that the protests were peaceful they
weren't peaceful yeah look at what
happened with the Nashville six yeah
almost immediately you know the
Democrats they they what they start
saying the Nashville three they shift
the entire narrative to these Democrats
who get ousted for an Insurrection at
their state capital Insurrection you
think that all the institution all the
colleges I mean obviously not all okay
this is a huge question so I don't know
if you've been following the work by
Chris Ruffo uh at new college in Florida
and other places so he is working hard
to dismantle diversity bureaucracies and
speaking of which we are in Austin and
one of the things that I'm doing is I'm
a founding faculty at the University of
Austin and there's been none of this
at the University of Austin I
can assure you there's none of this
how's that going is it is it is
it phenomenal phenomenal well over 100
million dollars we got whoa yeah is it a
new University or yep yep it's free
speech University it's what a university
should be it's a university a
traditional University kind of one how
old is it now it's well it's the first
class we have a summer program The
Forbidden classes program it'll be
online 2024. we got to get a high-speed
rail in this city now well okay out here
we're gonna be able to spread out is it
is it online only no it's on ground only
on ground yeah and they have classes
this summer I'll be teaching the
Forbidden classes the Kathleen stock
with gender Mark and reason Neil
Ferguson ion her CLE how big how big is
it how many square feet what do you got
no we it's just it's literally being
constructed now wow it's in Austin but
so you ask a great question what
percentage of universities so I think a
question is what percentage of the
people believe are caught in the orbit
of the ideology we don't really know the
answer to that question because they've
been so successful at creating a culture
of fear that
people won't honestly admit if they
believe the these truly deranged
propositions so we don't really know but
we we know from whether or not there are
offices of diversity Equity inclusion
which are virtually every University if
not everyone maybe not Hillsdale Liberty
the conservative we know that there are
bias response teams at over 150
universities uh two excuse me 250
universities where you can and that's
from Julian Melcher in the Wall Street
Journal published that a few years ago
it's been updated where people can
students or anyone can file a report
that is lodged with the police if they
even for basically For Thought crimes so
our universities are experiencing
ideological capture this has been the
base of my disagreement with Tim the
base of my disagreement with Tim is that
this is the nucleation point this is the
point that it from which it all erupts
and what we haven't talked about at all
but I probably should mention because
it's so important for context is that
you I can't you know all my Publications
Etc or someone let me take it off myself
someone who has a lot of Publications
research go to Google Scholar teaching
deck or quarter Century of teaching Etc
et cetera I can't somebody like that
can't just go into the public schools
and start teaching you need a teaching
certificate all of the colleges of
Education that Grant teaching
certificates they're literally all of
them are woke they're predicated on
Paula first pedagogy the Press Jim James
Lindsay guest of your show your friend
also talks about this pretty extensively
this is a woke indoctrination meal for
teachers in K-12 systems and we get this
madness so
I think I just I disagree with you I
think you're wrong okay
what we saw with like um what was his
name Nick christakis was that his name
yeah Nicholas Christopher Nicholas
christakis Prince the students oh no
Yale Yale sorry freshman students
already had this ideology within them
right they brought it to the
universities correct and the
universities said the customer is always
right and then recycled back to them
what they were demanding right so they
okay but so you're essentially making my
point unless I'm not understanding
you're not understanding okay these
these 16 year olds are on Facebook
they're they're 10 years old they get a
Facebook account they're not supposed to
but they do yeah they see nothing but
this weird algorithmic garbage they
enter the university and they demand
these changes and the schools say yes
because you pay our bills but you're
saying people from the University gate
keep who gets to teach at the elementary
school yeah we're not disagreeing
the point was the universe that's what
I'm so right right what I'm saying is
the universities did not originate this
the I there's elements of the ideology
that obviously you can trace back to
Academia what I'm saying is the
universities have these things within
them because young people were
manipulated brought it to the
universities and demanded it okay so if
the causal explanation for this is
solely algorithmic manipulation then how
is it given that you yourself have said
there are an awful lot of ideologies
then how is it that it's a what an
utterly remarkable coincidence that's
the ideology taught in universities and
it's the same one that the ideology
pushes when that's way too much when did
it become when did we start seeing these
these protests this this uproar the far
left experience it's been over the past
10 years it has quite literally been
since Lexus Nexus status points out the
emergence of social media Around the
World created an expansion of this
ideology it seems like you're both have
a touch of my side bias because you're a
student of the internet Tim and you're a
student of the Academia it seems and
you're both right it's a Confluence of
events
he's disagreeing with me which is fine
what I'm saying what I'm saying is
the algorithms Amplified our our our
mental our world view at the same time
as we started seeing the emergence of
the far left stuff we also saw an
expansion of white nationalism I got it
critical pedagogy started before social
media so critic critical pedagogy was
the precursor to that those people got
social media Alyssa all these people
they are innocent they actually are you
know everybody wants to be a victim this
is John Heights is a victim culture it
is a victim culture but they are
actually victims they're epistemic
victims of a deranged ideology those
people
were then placed in seats of power from
K through 12 up they've been getting
that so the kids who came to Yale
they've been indoctrinated with that
stuff for years this is what I don't
quite understand how it's an ideology
well it is it's a suite of beliefs right
the systemic racism racism is baked into
the system privilege seeks to preserve
itself all of those things
okay well you've mentioned that a few
times I'm trying not to go down that
rabbit hole but but this is a huge a
huge okay but no no but it's not a huge
hole but it's it's also a lot of
conservatives believe that too you know
just talked to Douglas Murray the other
day there's there's uh Douglas Mari was
in Ukraine he is for the United States I
mean again I'm trying to that's that's
to go I'm trying not to go down to the
Ukraine thing but you you have it it's
just like it's supposed cryptocurrency
too it's just like Chris
has some great stuff on that for why
that is it's it's a they're also very
pro-vaccine and toxicity it's a toxin to
work but all those things are in the
orbit of the ideology
and all of it in essence of mindless
adherence or
what do you mean like how is being at
war in Ukraine opposing cryptocurrencies
and being pro uh big pharmaceutical
companies in any way Associated I mean
in fact I would argue the the the being
in favor of massive multinational
corporations is actually it's
paradoxical it's kind of like joining
the military yeah assuming this this
Consciousness like if Joe Biden tells
you then you're gonna do it they've
accepted people some people have
accepted whatever they say okay so so
two things one what Ronald Reagan said
in his famous debate there you go again
you're assuming and I don't mean that as
a as a slander on you but you're
assuming a kind of rationality that the
proponents of the ideology have that
they simply do not have oh I'm quite the
opposite I'm saying they quite literally
have no rationality and there is no
coherent ideology at all what we're
looking at is a sewer of refuse that has
been mashed together yeah and what's
happened is I think regular people who
are looking for answers seek experts who
are and they find academics who then
give them a very academic explanation
okay okay so let's talk about a sewer
that's been crammed together and
force-fed right who's doing the force
feeding the algorithms
okay again I'm not saying you're wrong
I'm saying I'm telling you in no
uncertain terms the data is utterly
overwhelming for this for the people
force-feeding them are people who have
gone through teacher training programs
colleges of Education their University
their University administrators we
released a a show Lyle Asher released a
show on my YouTube channel why colleges
are becoming Cults we know why this is
true and the the likelihood that two
ideologies that the same ideology could
be both promoted in K-12 and academic
institutions and be promoted by the
algorithm at the same time is virtually
zero so Jack Dorsey who pushed the Free
Speech winning the Free Speech party
until 2014 who also lied before Congress
and hasn't been subject to perjury yet
go ahead go ahead pre uh the original
Twitter when it was created was the Free
Speech wing of the Free Speech party
when he created Twitter it was in in a
similar vein to the Ron Paul revolution
of Freedom libertarianism Etc and then
there was a shift now it's entirely
possible that the the explosion of data
points from we see from Lexus Nexus
Lexus Nexus in every country on the
planet the exact same time could be
because a globalist cabal got together
sat around a a table and said Implement
order wokeness our plan has come to
fruition and then they activated the
device which turned every country into a
woke you know disaster zone or it could
be that the Advent of cellular
technology put a phone in everyone's
pocket and then we gave everyone access
to communication devices which Amplified
our social biases okay creating two two
things an interesting thing in countries
like Iran and China that an inverse
conversation they went completely
anti-woke but still saw the emergence of
the same language okay let me ask you a
question then
taking everything that you just said
what is the disconfirmation criteria for
that like what piece of evidence or
rationale or Reason would you have to
hear that that would throw that
speculation or hypothesis into question
the Lexus Nexus data that's been
repeated on multiple occasions was
incorrect
the data is falsified uh that the
tracking of this terminology and the
rise of this language was misinterpreted
and in fact has always been around
something like that you could see the
algorithmic code over the last 15 years
if you had like snapshots of the code on
a weekly database to see like was the
algorithm actually inviting this
discourse I spoke at universities after
Occupy Wall Street yeah I did not see
this I I what year was that this is 20
uh end of 2011 I was being invited to
speak at University into 2012 and 2013
and then yeah I don't think it came to
prominence it's also we have um it
didn't come to prominence in the
universities well well I'm just
literally just going to say it's also a
geographical phenomenon so for example
it's New York it's yeah well it's worse
on the coast it's worse in traditionally
blue places uh when I was at Occupy Wall
Street lokeness was just starting to
permeate into the leftist ideology and
it was confusing to a lot of people when
I went and spoken universities follow
occupy following Occupy Wall Street all
of the journalists were class all of the
professors were classically liberal they
were very much in that in that
classically liberal vein where I am
right now and you probably are and then
over the next few years I am especially
with what we saw with gamergate we saw
the expansion of wokeness which came
from the internet and from young people
into the universities and then what we
ended up seeing was a lot of people you
can see the effect with celebrities you
can see the effect with corporations
slowly start adopting what they think is
is prominent and I think they do it let
me I'll give you what you're looking for
let me I'll give you what you're looking
for read the algorithm let me ask you a
question let's say we had a pie chart
and I'm claiming that it's K-12 College
of Education College administrators
infused throughout the curriculum
diversity statements all of the stuff
that seek to both indoctrinate students
in an indoctrination Mill and perpetuate
the ideology let's say that you had two
of those and they're not competing and
you're going to fit them in a pie chart
what percentage of that of that pie
chart is algorithm and what percentage
of it is academic institutions so so
what do you mean you mean like right
it's responsible for the freaking
catastrophe responsible 100 algorithm
then our disagreement is far more
substantive than I thought yeah I so so
the issue is
when
I I think what's happening is people are
seeking answers as to what this ideology
is they're seeing specific examples of
it they're uh many people are looking at
the news in a very short-term
perspective and then they're following
experts who they believe are academics
uh I'm sorry academics who they believe
are experts on the subject matter and
who likely are in the specifics of say
you know critical race Theory and
critical theory but they're not actually
looking at the Hard data of the social
phenomenon that's occurred
and and the strange thing to me is like
as I often try to explain there's
hundreds of thousands of ideologies that
existed in universities 20 years ago and
sort of still do but they're being
pushed out all the pre-social media pre
uh these this wokeness did not exist at
all it was at all good and so uh simply
put when Anheuser-Busch says
I don't want my content appearing next
to these things these things get removed
from social media yeah it's an
amplification machine that keeps
spinning up and recycling these
ideologies which keep changing name and
there's there I think the issue is
you know I'm on the ground at Occupy
Wall Street I'm on the ground at various
protests in La all across the country
I'm in Spain and I'm seeing similar
things and I'm seeing similar behaviors
that don't have a core ideological
function and then today I'm seeing
pro-vaccine stuff I'm seeing profoti
stuff I'm seeing Pro Biden stuff I'm
seeing vote blue no matter who always
use your corporeal
childpot GPT too and I'm seeing uh
Ukraine war stuff none of these things
fit your argument now it is true I think
that universities have become Mills of
wokeness but I think Within These Mills
it makes no sense that there's a rainbow
flag next to a Ukraine flag there is no
ideology that brings these things
together what does however is a social
media algorithm that says adhere to
Orthodoxy
okay or straight up the President
telling people to do it and they're so
afraid of Donald Trump that they're just
falling in line why are they even afraid
of Donald Trump because they're like
psychology poisoning the food supply
during the TV for four four hours a day
eight hours a day where in in these
theories these ideologies is Trump
derangement syndrome
uh so the the Trump derangement syndrome
as far as I know I'm sure someone's
written a paper about it but that's just
something that's people have used that
often often say conservatives have used
uh Sam Harris is an interesting thing
about Trump trump derangements well he's
Trump deranged
the dude is Sam Harris is clearly
unwilling to reflect upon himself he's a
perfect example of what he's complained
about with Islam he doesn't self-reple
reflect upon the fact that he's wrong at
all he doesn't look at any of the data
he just hates Donald Trump to the point
where he said he believed it was good to
cheat to win elections all right wanna
so here's my suggestion to you why don't
you have him on and have a conversation
with him oh yeah absolutely I mean
anything so but but the point is Trump
derangement syndrome exists in the left
refers to it as Trump what do they call
Trump anxiety disorder and so you what
just to be clear for for people
listening by Trump derangement syndrome
you mean
when people become irrationally angry at
the thought of Donald Trump the
truth-telling around Donald Trump or
anything he does but I would also for
example when they said that the
terrorist was an austere scholar they
either anything he does is framed
negatively and any defense of him in any
factual stance like hey you know Trump
when he when he threw the fish with
Shinzo ABI into the koi pond yeah Shinzo
Abe actually did it first they say
you're a trump supporter they get
irrationally angry Sam Harris being a
good example he says that Sam Harris
believes subverting elections is a good
thing because Trump is that bad he said
Sam Harris actually said that if there
was legitimate evidence of Hunter Biden
sexually abusing children it would not
be as bad as Donald Trump running a
fraud University I heard that that is
now now where in leftist ideology does
that exist it doesn't what does is that
Sam Harris is beholden to Liberal social
Orthodoxy crafted by algorithms and he
doesn't want to break from it I'll tack
on part two of the definition of trump
derangement syndrome is that when people
are obsessively in love with Donald
Trump it's another form of derangement
the cult worship that kind of thing
blinded hearing people I agree with you
what people don't use the word to mean
that but you're so yeah okay so there's
so much to unpack in this so when people
are accused of trump derangement
syndrome they will give the response
that that is a a slur that people use
who whitewash
the fact that Donald Trump and I'm not
saying I'm well I I gotta hear this yeah
it's it's that that Donald Trump is an
enemy of democracy and he has subverted
the democracy and he would not leave
office uh allegedly and he's a traitor
and whatever else happens
well their their response is not that
this is an irrational hatred of Donald
Trump it's that this is a rational
hatred of Donald Trump but but we but
any objective and I mean this literally
yeah any objective person knows that it
is irrational when uh I mean Donald
Trump was impeached why because he made
a phone call uh to Ukraine asking about
Joe Biden withholding congressionally
approved Aid in exchange for a political
favor okay so
I agree with you I agree that but again
perhaps see difference of disability
simply put these people believe that
because social media algorithms fed them
false narratives and lies
now they say that uh every cell in our
body is completely changed within seven
years that means someone alive today
their entire I don't know if it's true
but well I just I'm just making a
nonsensical point but wives tale the
point is a person's entire being if
they've been following corporate news
since 2015 is comprised of life that
believes all of these psychotic lies
about Donald Trump yeah that that we
have debunked over and over and over
again and I don't think Trump's a saint
I don't think he's the greatest
president who's ever lived or anything
like that I think on foreign policy he's
the best I've seen in my lifetime I can
tell you all the things that I didn't
didn't like what you've done what he's
done I can say that I was wrong when I
took his side over Thomas Massey
and then you go and talk to somebody and
it's it's become a Trope stop making me
defend Trump was a Trope throughout 2016
2017 when the media would lie they
accused Donald Trump of being a traitor
and having served the Russians as he was
president and there are people I
remember that who still believe this
yeah now that's Trump derangements yeah
okay and that's well that sense I think
I think it's really important your point
is really important that
and and I think it's really important
when we make mistakes that we've had
about things in the past that we kind of
fess up to them that's why I fessed up
to you about the hunter Biden laptop and
we had fall for that so I did think I
did buy into a lot of that media
narrative that maybe why he seems
unnaturally close to Russia something's
going on they lied why
well I heard a lot of that there's a
tape it said I'm sure you've heard that
Russian ladies of the night yeah you
heard that drinking a lot of Beverages
and this is my point social media
algorithms we're feeding this content to
people because it got clicks so what we
saw was yeah I mean again Tim there's
I'm not disagreeing with it all right
this is a huge problem I I don't I'm not
disagreeing with you I don't know how to
get out of it so yeah which is why I
mentioned the my side bias which is
making it worse yeah I think that we get
out of it in a few ways I think people
who are aware of the issue
should have as many kids as possible I
know everyone points to me and ask me
where my kids are you know personal
issues but we'll talk about you know
I'll keep that private so I think people
should have as many kids as possible
that doesn't mean your kids will think
like you there's no guarantee but the
there's also a combination of factors
one get out of cities we we you know we
see what's going on with with Riley
Gaines we see what's going on in Austin
with um Daniel Perry the lies the media
is pushing on this guy it's incredible
So Daniel Perry's gotta or get off
social media altogether like lucianov
has been saying or John Hyde free kids
young girls liberal girls yes young
women white take your kids phones away
yeah take your oh no it's actually it's
interesting it's not YouTube it's not
it's strictly social media it's the
problem that height found yeah yeah your
kids should not be on social media so
like they shouldn't have phones I don't
think they should have something well
that's another thing there's no again
I'm not familiar with the data I haven't
looked into it but people who are
familiar with the data say it's not
watching YouTube it's not reading books
it's not texting it's strictly social
media I will clarify they have these
cell phones that can only make make and
receive phone calls and texts those are
totally fine in my opinion you know I
thought you guys were saying something
interesting about Trump derangement
syndrome you're saying that it's like an
irrational fear of this and you're
saying that it's considered a rational
yeah I'm saying that the people accused
of trump derangement syndrome will claim
that they don't it's not a syndrome it's
a that it's not irrational it's rational
I think that's for sure and I'm trying
to look up what does that even mean
what's rationality it's something that
you can claim based on a reason what's a
reason well something that you think is
right what's an Hedonism like it's it's
so subjective this this stuff but this
is I actually think that's a really good
point when we're trying to break down
why these people think they're rational
they think they have a reason for it the
reason I say that they are Trump
deranged is the emotional Vigor that
comes along with it you come to me and
you tell me that Donald Trump was an
evil Tyrant I'll say why do you think
that yeah I go to them and I say I think
Donald Trump was the greatest president
foreign policy they lose their minds
yeah okay there's something there's
something really profound to that right
there's something that
people who can't engage they just get EX
like anthropogenically warming right
like anthropogenic global warning
if you make an argument against it or if
you make it or no matter what your
argument is there are some people who
will say well what's your evidence and
there are other people who will lose
their minds and this is the point I'm
making ultimately about the modern left
and wokeness is that climate change
Trump derangement syndrome and Ukraine
uh fauci none of these things line up
with Academia but they are deranged on
all of these counts and equally
defensible on all of these counts what's
the best way to figure out if someone
should fear a president
I think
looking at history and uh figuring out
how you should fear a president you look
at history you probably fear all of them
including Donald Trump
amen absolutely so you you don't think
that Trump presented maybe unique is too
strong of word you don't think that
Trump presented a an especially
dangerous threat to our democracy why do
you say our democracy well I mean the
United States as opposed to Canadian
demand Trump represented probably this
the the best effort we had at a Saving
Grace of America of the American
constitutional republic you mean the
whole clearing the Swamp Thing not
necessarily
um my view of trump is that he was more
like a bull in a china shop and that the
Ivory Tower has been constructed over
the past hundred years probably since
just before 1913. okay let me let me ask
you this question on a scale from one to
ten
we should fear Donald Trump how much and
and we should fear Biden how much Biden
well it's tough It's not so much Biden
himself but Biden for for all that's
around him I would put it at an eight or
a nine and Trump I'd put it a
six five or a six okay so so this is
really interesting I want to say
something so every time I've asked you a
question you've given me an answer and I
know that that must sound like well of
course I've given you an answer because
you've asked me a question that I
consider it reasonable maybe if I ask
you a question about your sex life you
wouldn't answer the question but maybe
he would or maybe he would I don't know
I wouldn't ask him so I wouldn't ask him
so it doesn't make a difference but
there is something also
I think it's an element of that Trump
derangement syndrome that you mentioned
that you may there's a kind of
excitability or a kind of anger in that
or a kind of like when you ask someone a
question they get upset that you ask
them the question absolutely or they
don't want the questions asked at all
and that I think is more of a concern of
the byproduct of what's happening to
people's Consciousness and how they
engage each other
right because they go on social media
and they are told this is what you must
be whether it's true or false this and I
wonder if it has it's a component of low
testosterone or just outside of that
argument agreeableness individuals who
fear being ostracized because of you
know humans survive by being in in
social groups and those who are more
willing to take risks to lead if it's
the right thing so leaders versus
followers the people who are more likely
to fall into the follower category are
like don't challenge the order I will
not have you get me ostracized yeah
whereas my view is kind of like
ostracize me I don't care I'll do fine
on my own so I have I don't have that
fear that these people probably do they
get angry because their brain
understands that what is being told to
them is likely true but if it's true it
means the social order they're they're
using to survive is wrong now they're
faced with the The evolutionary fear of
a risk to their lives yeah so that's the
question how do you help people
in the literature it's called build a
golden bridge like how do you help
people walk over who are awoke and I'm
thinking like you know now I'm thinking
the FBI is going to come for me when I
say red pills
it's already through my social credit
score terrible
um you know and how do you help people
and not create adversarial relationships
to say oh wow geez you know I thought
this and made
Anheuser-Busch we need that apology more
than anything right now we need that
apology we need to say to every single
person who is blindly following social
Orthodoxy you're on the wrong side of
History because that's what they say
because that's what they fear okay
that's by the way as I've told Reid a
thousand times that's the I've lost of
five friends now because of my stances
on things and four of those five people
all for woke reasons four of those five
people have said to me the same thing
you're on the wrong side of History
exactly I hear that constantly and
that's the only thing they have that
attaches them to any of these arguments
they might make or any of these Flag
icons they'll put in their profiles or
in their Windows is that they fear being
on the wrong side of history for one
reason being shunned from the majority
means death figuratively but in the past
for humans literally if Anheuser-Busch
apologizes we get The High Ground and we
say you're on the wrong side of history
on this one then they get scared and
I'll start to ask them so elves uh oh
are we gonna lose this one yeah should I
be with them you know people often ask
well what are some of the things you're
sure you're right about in the culture
well to me it's pretty obvious don't
defund the police that's freaking insane
the other thing is child gender
affirmation gender affirming care
that is one I hear a lot of I I've
mentioned to my friends years ago why
don't you write down something three
years ago why don't you write down the
beliefs that you have now that are new
that you've acquired in the last
year or two and why don't we revisit
those in five years and see where we are
hence the wrong side of history people
and that's my other prediction too you
think you're smart don't think you're
smart make predictions my predictions
they'll be massive gaslighting at the
end of this oh I never believe this and
absolutely I think yeah because it's so
ghastly they'll have to Gaslight well if
they want to be a part of the Moral
Majority there you go again that's the
and that's not the tribalism but the the
one thing people want more than being
right is to belong right it's to be
loved it's to be a member of a community
wokeness offers that very very easily
the signaling the pronouns in the bio
Etc we're going to go to super chats
went a little long so if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends and head over
to timcast.com click join us become a
member because we're gonna have a
members only uncensored show at about 10
10 p.m where that's where we're more
likely to swear and be not so family
friendly and maybe get a little bit
darker with the conversation so you
don't want to miss it and you can also
join the Discord server after you
remember where you can hang out with
like-minded individuals and then if you
join the 25 level or your member for at
least six months even call into the show
and ask questions of us and our guests
but let's read super chats all right
Freedom Jeffrey 1776 says hi Tim can't
wait to see you guys Friday in Austin
awesome will we be able to take video in
the venue
I don't know are we live it's live
should be fine right and I yeah but
there might be venue rules so I want to
say I don't I would love for people to
be able to yeah talk about building a
golden bridge yeah it's totally fine
with it and I think after the show too
we're going to give Ian a guitar and
make them play music oh yes let's do it
frequent measure because we've got uh I
think a couple hours after the show of
like what do you want to do that's how
you bridge the golden bridge like you
need you need people to come to your
show that are woke and that I love
Donald Trump and they all don't even
know they don't ask doesn't matter
they're just I agree more they look at
each other as people yes all right uh
one yeah let me read some more speeches
Raymond Jesus otherwise we'll talk
forever Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim I
enjoyed the Jorge segment always nice
shining a light uh in it's when it's the
darkest before the dawn we are based
Chads on that red pill and oh oops sorry
FBI I kid go f your shelves let's go
Brandon yeah Jorge uh mazvidol this is
the one of the greatest moments I just I
can't believe this happened Donald Trump
sitting with Mike Tyson Kid Rock and
Dana White watching a UFC fight and then
Jorge wins and then gives a shout out to
Trump as the greatest president and then
says let's go Brandon and the whole
crowd is cheering let's go Brandon as
Joe Rogan is holding the microphone
how is this real life but uh talk about
a white pill moment the whole audience
yelling let's go Brandon yeah hey
Miami's awesome I've been in Miami the
last few months I love it there the
people there are incredible lots of
anti-communist Cubans out there that I
resonate my uh dislike for Communists as
a polish-born person so beautiful place
Beautiful People Grant recommended
enough Grant says the real victory of
the Budweiser boycott is making Bud
Light the drink of the left and forcing
them to buy and drink lots of Bud Light
I saw a funny post they said Bud Light
is the beer for people who don't want to
drink beer but want to drink lots of it
[Laughter]
if you want to wipe someone out that's
another way of doing it like hey yeah
there's a big thing about hey go take
this other product from what big Pharma
when low tar cigarettes were popular
people smoke twice as much of them
yeah there's a lot of water in water but
alive I think it's floodlight's a
terrible beer I know like I'm not saying
that for any other reason it's just a
terrible beer independent it's got to be
like one of the worst beers yeah it's
just so basic Bland not very tasty I
think that's why they people tend to go
for it because it's not old it's rice
beer yeah I I I'm not I'm into like I
like the thicker stoutier yeah
you said Newcastle I love Newcastle
Brown
number one to drink beer too many carbs
yeah I don't like beer all right let's
read some more max Reddick says Mary
Hassan is an evil person oh god he's a
lunatic he is defending the government
on the Twitter files arguing semantics
saying the government simply pointed out
to Twitter that people were breaking
their rules insane well it's not just
he's not an honest broker of
conversation none of these people are
he's just not honest just none of these
people are yeah he's been in the news
pretty heavily so can I can I just can I
just talk about that just for a quick so
it's taken me a lot a lot of work
to to really get into my mind that some
people have absolutely nothing of
substance to add to a conversation and
in fact even listening to them is a kind
of cognitive poison it's like a slow
epistemic punch in the head
uh oh my gosh I get this thing sometimes
people will be talking right and they'll
say right at the end of the sentence and
I have to turn the video off when it's
happening because I'm like I'm not going
to get brainwashed and it's talking like
that right all right right right all
right uh Max also says Tim I know you
don't like to say when guests are coming
on but would you mind breaking that rule
once and let us know when the Surfs are
coming on I need to see that guy get
pressed so uh what's it what's that
guy's name my aunts Lance yeah I mean he
tweets at me and as I come on the show
because I always do like whenever a
leftist tweets at me or something I'll
be like bro you're welcome to come on
the show so that's okay so that's vital
and that's piggybacking off what you
said when people with whom you have a
disagreement you know like I've had a
disagreement with Matt Walsh I invited
him to conversation of course he doesn't
respond
I think that's one of the things you
have going for if someone disagrees with
you I've always heard you say in the
past we'd love to have a conversation
and then 97 of leftists ignore it or lie
or turn it into a drama moment 100 and
they say Tim doesn't talk to people he
disagrees with right I get that
constantly well why don't you go on
left-wing media well because I'm not
invited on left-wing media you know we
invited one guy on the show and he
publicly says I'll do it and then
privately I'm not going on your show
yeah and then he takes it and turns it
into a segment where he's like Tim
Poole's scared to debate me and all this
stuff and I'm like so there you go I
mean that but that's their tactic right
it's a woke tactic but this dude from
the Surfs uh tweeted at me and I said
come on the show and he was like are you
serious hell yeah I'm like awesome dude
I look forward to it like you're allowed
to have your your opinions man and we'll
talk about them we've had uh we've had
Destiny the Omni liberal on a couple
times you know a lot of people don't
like him they disagree with him he gets
things wrong or whatever but I'm like I
think Destiny's great and he's going to
be here Saturday you want to hear
something totally crazy I am in Romania
giving talks doing all the stuff and I'm
like walking on a back road in the
middle of freaking nowhere and some this
is a totally true story and this woman
comes running up to me and says oh my
God oh my God I saw you on Destiny
in the middle yeah in the middle of
nowhere in some Village in Romania wow
yeah I'm going to tell him that story
all right oh snap it's Dave says Luke
liquor stores stayed open because people
who drink on the daily if kovid didn't
kill them the DTs would have quitting
drinking cold is worse than the needle
your liver goes in complete shock
absolutely yep um totally right I'm not
disagreeing with you but the Optics were
still bad when the government was
shutting down mom and pop businesses and
churches and churches but but liquor
stores were okay and I understand
there's medical reasons uh that's how
addictive some of this stuff is the
church thing to me is the most egregious
because it's the first amendment yeah it
is like the most vital
for for us to experience life as we as
we understand it and they shut churches
down I mean that just that blew my mind
that's crazy all right all right I'll
read some more
Wrath of Paul says the Bud Light Fiasco
only distracts us from the bigger issues
that actually kill our freedom such as
the impending collapse of the Petro
dollar and the implementation of cbdcs
around the world well my view is not so
uh simple on the petrodollar I think
it's actually that's I think the Petro
dollar is dying it's been dying for for
a decade plus if you see the curve it's
going down and Donald Trump's view this
is my my personal view I I could be
totally wrong I got to ask the guy but I
think he sees this and he says if we
don't secure our borders if we don't
bring back manufacturing if we don't get
the American people back to work when
the Petro dollar Falls we're done and
the Democrats were like no no no Trump
you're wrong we should destroy the
planet before the Petro dollar Falls
and so even though it's still going to
fall they're like war in Ukraine at any
cost and now we got those Pentagon leaks
which assuming that a reel shows that
Russia actually ain't losing that
Ukrainian Air Defense Forces are going
to be depleted by the end of May that
the money we just sent to Ukraine is not
enough and that only around eight
percent of Russian troops that have been
reported have actually died so when they
say 200 000 the numbers from these leaks
17.
now the argument is that these are these
are it's propaganda and the numbers are
manipulated and the language in the
context is all manipulated perhaps has
there been a statement from the Pentagon
if it's true or false according to the
military analysts the people pretty much
speaking for the Pentagon they're like
yeah everything here release this is
true but they just faked the numbers
here for this specific reason which is
very convenient to our official story
that's what they're going with here but
there's a lot of other things going uh
going around I was talking about this in
my YouTube video today specifically with
China brokering or peace deal between
Iran and Saudi Arabia Saudi Arabia has
just called for the end end of the
yemenoir which is a proxy war they're
bringing the sunnis and Chi ice together
there's a big move here against the
dollar here and this is going directly
against Israel and Americans foreign
policy in the Middle East which is going
to be uh some some very significant
ramifications for you know uh I'm
reading this this uh here super chat
about Ian and I think Ian's right Duncan
Chestnut says Ian landed a 20 here
apology is not enough make them an
example going well could collapse your
company not just inconvenience it and
you know what and I I think that's
actually a decent Point what I was
saying earlier is that if they apologize
then we go out and we buy as much of
their product as possible because what
we want people to see is we want all of
the analysts to be alike well when they
when they did this ad campaign their
stock collapsed and their sales
collapsed when they apologized for it
they made a billion dollars so I don't
understand why would we want to punish
them for apologizing it's not about
apologizing it's that if they don't well
so that's what he's saying apologies not
enough make him an example my view is if
they don't apologize then I hope they
completely collapse I guess then the
message is oh that I'm 100 fine with but
if they apologize then apologizing for
doing something wrong should be rewarded
but you shouldn't do Aristotle actually
says sorry but you shouldn't do a bad
thing
to feel remorse you should feel remorse
only once you've done a bad thing sorry
if someone walks up to somebody and just
punches them and knocks them on the
ground and stands there and goes sorry
I'm not buying it bro I'm not gonna buy
your beer you just deck that guy like no
no no no apology is not enough and
that's it this is different they just
smeared Dylan Mulvaney they made a fool
of him and they wrecked their brand yeah
let's drag for this well let's make it a
little different
a group of people are standing in a big
circle and there's a guy named uh Bush
and you know and and then another guy
staying next to him and everyone's
yelling so the bush guy goes all right
I'll please these people and just
punches the dude as hard as he can like
you described however everyone starts
booing and then the guy's like what's
what's happening why are you booing me I
thought that's what you wanted and they
were like no we don't want to do this
and now we're gonna take you down he
goes I'm sorry I'm sorry yeah I don't
think he's actually sorry I think he's
scared and I think when he then yells
out to everyone I am scared of you
please stop it sends a message to every
other Corporation if you want to see
your net worth plummet by four billion
dollars play that game so so for you
correct me if I'm wrong this bush thing
is kind of like a Line in the Sand and
this is where we can actually do
something to make a substantive change
well I'll be honest you know I Dylan
Mulvaney is a product uh as Vivek
ramaswami said in a rather brilliant
fashion we thought the AI monster we we
would have to deal with is going to be a
robot with laser eyes but it's Dylan
Mulvaney it's it's the manipulation
young people are experiencing at the
hands of social media and so it's not so
much a Line in the Sand when the story
dropped I didn't care when I first saw
the story that Dylan Mulvaney was being
spot was was being sponsored by Bud
Light I went well how about that but
when Kid Rock then fired at a bunch of
Bud Light I said okay I will do a short
segment about this and so it wasn't even
a main segment for me and then I got 1.5
million views and I said okay people
have rallied around this idea and begun
a boycott and then Travis Tritt came out
later an event got canceled and I said
this might be the moment people actually
decide I can do some good here and so
with that I said okay let's follow the
story and see what's happening now that
we're seeing real economic consequences
for me it's opportunity it is finally we
have a four billion dollar get what go
broke and everyone one is piling on and
then the media started attacking me and
I said over Target can I just um if I
may put in a plug for my two passions so
Star Trek has been destroyed Star Trek
Discovery has been destroyed by woke
Madness it's turned the show into a
living cesspool
Doctor Who the last two seasons have
been utterly destroyed and I would like
to add if I may I would like apologies
for destroying the franchise for those
for from both the BBC you know
destroying Terry nation's work and
destroying Star Trek so please add those
to your list uh I canceled by Paramount
yeah Star Trek was uh
it's one of my favorites next generation
of course Deep Space Nine and uh the
first problem I had is they only do c
they only do prequels
so boring and uh then they you know get
well go bro so it's unfortunate but the
prequel thing didn't bother me but the
woke Arc the woke story everything about
it was intersect I couldn't stand it
it's destroy the franchise all right
let's read some more we got insane
redneck he says regarding encryption my
brother just finished his time in the
Army and just started work as a fort
guard he told me the dod has classes for
staff purely for the sake of bypassing
vpns
unsurprising Brandon Allen says look at
Luke rocking that cowboy hat based LARP
I'm not laughing this is what I always
wanted he's making a jug
I know
[Laughter]
all right let's see uh what do we got DL
says chickens with Pew pews you're not
taking the eggs this time quick someone
meme that side note ever think of Quicks
quick access app with sub that includes
all your sub based media for one low
monthly price using access code
um the app's done the issue is it's
really hard to get an app on on I on on
the app store for iTunes but I think the
Android app is going up really soon and
this means that you can log in and get
access to all of the content and it'll
be really easy to navigate and uh really
excited for it super cool I have to say
you're you're I'm just watching this now
boy your viewers are really thoughtful
some of these comments are just
fantastic comments are incredible I'm
always in the comment section always
commenting well comments are really
thoughtful but we get we get Corrections
in real time too yeah like we said
something wrong I I can see it and I'm
like oh hey guys someone just pointed
out like we've gotten guns wrong and and
do you say hey I made a mistake oh yeah
yeah so that's what differentiates you
from right I mean just think about how
silly it would be if someone super chats
you said the name of the gun wrong it
was actually this and then I went well I
don't care I'm not correcting like
they're literally listening right to
each other right and they know I'm wrong
the only thing I can do is be like I got
that one wrong yeah so you have a good
audience that's good that's really good
smart people posting smart comments they
listen I read every difference in a
crowd that just watches for kind of in
the background and people that really
listen to the stuff yeah content these
people listen here's a good one Miguel D
says I'm a staunch conservative and I'm
sounding more like Bernie Sanders every
day billionaires are the problem they
own the corrupt media big Tech and pay
off the politicians is it billionaires
or is it money that's the problem no
it's it's neither it's
it's not even billionaires Elon musk's a
billionaire the problem is corruption
they're bad people exist you know look a
bad guy who's poor can go murder a bunch
of people a bad guy who's very wealthy
can cause massive destruction culturally
and politically
it's still just bad people doing bad
things you know Elon Musk is you know
he's I got my criticisms of them you can
talk about his his deference to China or
to whatever degree that that is he
denies it but then you can talk about
buying Twitter and taking the W off the
sign and then painting it white because
that landlord is a plane like it's great
he's a funny guy and he's doing good
things I do think the value of wealth
hoarding is a problem you really
shouldn't be valuable to not spend your
money that doesn't make any sense
currency is supposed to like a current
move
well this is why they do negative
interest rates you know they want to try
and get you to remove your money from
bank accounts and go spend it or
something
the whole monetary modern monetary
Theory I think is a big corrupt night
it's so crazy that people that have
billions just sit with it in a bank
account at two percent interest and then
they're just like they're richer they
make more money than I do I'm bullish on
bitcoin
all right what is this uh Barker Lewis
can't choose it's okay
uh the vague on his podcast with Bill
Burr talked about using and promoting
the FBI not reform it he is a wolf in
sheep's clothing
yeah for sure he is that's why you
should be following his work I I I think
there's a degree of hidden agenda to a
certain extent with Vivek but I mostly
think that uh he means it he knows what
he's talking about and when I talk to
him about his story about how he got
involved basically he ran a
multi-billion dollar company it was a
great interview he got attacked by woke
people it pissed him off because woke
Inc is a wonderful book for people who
haven't read it he I think he's he's
emotionally slighted by the fact that he
said sure I'll write a statement did and
they went it wasn't good enough and then
they resigned and he's like you you you
f with me you get the horns you know
what I mean and I think he's going to
play ball with the military industrial
complex he's been pretty straightforward
that he's going to be a different guy
after eight years in there and that's
why because he will decide where the
bombs fall I don't know about that he's
the real deal all I can say is Obama man
I think his I think he's more like a
right-wing Andrew Yang but I think he'd
run circles around Andrew Yang where
he's talking about a war with the
cartels the CIA is not going to be
happening those are two of my favorite
people by the way I've been talking
about the cartels what do we do about
that like do we mobilize the full force
of the American Military
proposal like declare war on Mexico and
use work with their government invade
the country becoming a narco State like
if they're letting cartels run their
country we have no choice but to take
control and seize the land I mean I
would even consider taking it if they're
not gonna govern and they're just gonna
let them attack us
another conversation that's a huge
conversation wait until you learn about
government Ian let's read some more we
got KCBS as Tim I do share your videos
occasionally if I find them if I find
them profound on Facebook and none of
them get any reactions it's impossible
that no one would give it a like even if
they don't watch your content is being
hidden by Facebook can confirm now what
you can do about it
um we started posting more and more onto
Facebook because it is a platform we
should be using to get access to more
people and uh we put them on on Rumble
as well I'm actually beginning to think
about uploading you know to Twitter
I think Twitter is an Avenue that's not
being explored properly right now with
Twitter blue you can actually upload
what is it like couple hours or
something is that what they're doing I
don't know it's a long time yeah so I'm
thinking maybe we need to just run uh
the timcast IRL Channel like we do for
Instagram and just start producing more
and more content for it
all right let's see what we got here
jomas says I install Steam boilers for a
living beer beers after a really dirty
one brings the guys together just saying
it's not all evil gents more morale
matters no that's why I say I like beer
I think beer is something fun I don't
I'm not gonna drink it but I understand
why people do totally I mean and and I
actually like blue moon but I haven't
had one I really try not to drink I
don't know you don't drink I try not to
drink at all I just love drinking I just
find it so enjoyable but I've I'm trying
to cut down on my carbs and I in my
wheat like so no sugars and no wheat or
minimal you know yeah and I feel better
when I'm at a better weight you know oh
yeah I think this healthy at every size
is BS but there is something about you
know some minimal diet cutting sugar and
minimizing alcohol although I will say
you know I so I went from gin and tonic
to uh half gin half tonic double gin to
quadruple gin a half tonic and that's
been working out for me and then I don't
have anything else yeah just replace the
beard with the beef liver just have a
bunch of beef liver with the boys well
it's hard alcohol I think is better for
you it's you know it's like that movie
from I think it's like the 80s where
they're shooting into the house and the
vampires are in the house they're
shooting in the house and the bullets
aren't hitting uh hurting the vampires
even though they're hitting them but
it's making holes in the in the barns
coming through yeah and the sun's coming
through and it's burning the vampires
that's what alcohol to me is it's the
sugar sugar that gets you all right
sugar let's grab one more idea Chris
men what does it say Chris Mandela is
that what it says Mendela billionaires
don't keep their money in their bank
accounts they invest in companies and
stocks most of these billionaires like
Elon have very little liquid cash most
of their worth is from stocks
particularly Elon everyone says it's
worth 200 billion but that's just stock
in Tesla you can't do anything with that
what they can do is take loans against
their stock and then they have a ton of
money and then they can cash out their
stock when they're allowed to and then
pay back loans and things like that and
pay a hefty tax bill which is right yeah
that's a lot of taxes so uh if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
if you really like it because that's the
most powerful way for podcasts to grow
is Word of Mouth head over to
timcast.com become a member because
we're gonna have an uncensored members
only show coming up in about 10 minutes
and if you join the Discord you can get
access to uh actually calling into the
show after six months of membership or
at least 25 bucks then we screen callers
and we choose a few every night so we
just started doing this recently and
it's the most fun thing I I think all
day so uh do that timcast.com you can
follow the show at timcastirl on
Instagram and I think everywhere and you
can follow me personally at timcast
Peter do you want to shout anything out
uh Peter bogosian I'm on Twitter at
Peter at Peter bogosian bog h-o-s-s-i-n
I have a YouTube channel I think it's if
you just put in Peter pogosian it will
come up and have a non-profit National
progress Alliance and we fight wokeness
and promote free speech and open
discourse full-time so appreciate the
same thing liking our Channel
subscribing and and sharing how do you
spell that again
[Music]
b-o-g-h-o-s-s-i-a-n Peter thank you so
much for coming on my YouTube channel is
youtube.com forward slash we are change
I started going live sporadically
randomly doing uh Little Talks if you
want to check that out definitely
subscribe I don't know when I don't have
a schedule so just make sure you're
subscribed there I'm also going to be
doing a members only meet up this
Thursday in Austin and if you want to
find out about that check out
lukeunfiltered.com Luke unfiltered.com
and I'm really excited to meet some of
you guys here in Austin I think we Luke
and I may be doing a video this week
yeah a live one it's going to be live
you guys on Luke's Channel we are
changed it was really fun listening to
you guys tonight Peter thanks for coming
man I appreciate it I appreciate it
thank you and I I want to say I really
enjoy the spirited discourse and I think
one of the reasons that your podcast has
been successful you and Rogan is because
you do have these kind of Inc and I like
it when people tell me I'm wrong like I
find that to be in that Tim Urban's book
what's our problem like that's the
higher level that's what you want to do
like that's a reason that cements and
glues friendships is people say you know
they call you out and you don't take it
personally I don't take it personally I
ask you a question you answer a question
I ask you a question so I think that
there's something
really lovely about that and that's what
cements relationships
and we also have Mr dupreya on the
microphone no camera though thank you
yeah no camera guys high energy surge in
the house yeah but uh yeah I'm just
hanging out all right everybody head
over to timcast.com for the uncensored
show and we will see you all in a few
minutes